kommt zum tagesordnungspunkt 11 b die
einzelgänger des bundeskanzleramtes für
die heutige aussprache haben wir
insgesamt eine redezeit von acht stunden
beschlossen
wir beginnen mit dem geschäftsbereich
der bundeskanzlerin und des
bundeskanzleramtes das wort hat die
fraktionsvorsitzende stehen doch klar
alles weiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
haushalt ist der nerv des staates daher
muss er den profanen augen der untertan
entzogen werden diesen satz der kardinal
richelieu zugeordnet wird
haben sie sich offensichtlich seit
jahrzehnten auf die fahnen geschrieben
denn pünktlich zur vorstellung des
haushaltes beginnt das tarnen und
täuschen statt dem souverän den bürgern
reinen wein einzuschenken werden
vollmundige sonntagsreden gehalten und
dabei fühlen sie sich dem schriftzug am
hohen hause dem deutschen volke ohnehin
nicht mehr verpflichtet das volk das
wollen sie sich nämlich selbst aussuchen
und zusammenstellen die rede von einer
schwarzen null
doch in wahrheit sitzen die steuerzahler
auf einem gewaltigen schuldenberg den
die künftigen generationen erben werden
dennoch binden uns die jeweiligen
finanzminister wie gestern auch olaf
scholz jahr für jahr einen bären auf wie
das gelingt ganz einfach im
bundeshaushalt werden schlicht nicht
alle ausgabenposten aufgeführt denn wo
es zum beispiel der usa zu finden
richtig nämlich gar nicht die rund 30
milliarden die deutschland nach brüssel
transferiert werden im budget
verschwiegen nachdem rexit wird der
posten sogar noch größer die haftungen
und garantien für andere euro staaten
banken und die diversen euro
rettungsfonds sind gigantisch ganz zu
schweigen von den tage zwei seiten mit
denen wir unsere exporte nämlich selbst
bezahlen und auch ist das nur ein teil
der tatsächlichen schulden überhaupt
veröffentlicht es ist nämlich die
schatten verschuldung die sie der
jüngeren generation wie ein mühlstein um
den hals gehängt haben und der
ökonomischen hat in seiner generation
bilanz nachgewiesen auf unglaubliche 7
billionen euro beläuft sich die
gesamtverschuldung die bund länder
gemeinden angehäuft haben
zuzüglich der zukünftigen
zahlungsverpflichtungen aus dem
gesetzlichen sozialversicherungssystem
und ihrer staatlichen pension und ich
stelle die frage ist das eigentlich noch
verantwortliches haushalten
sie reden von verantwortung doch in
wahrheit geben sie das königsrecht des
parlamentes die budgethoheit schamlos
aus der hand knowtech station resort
repräsentation keiner besteuerung ohne
zustimmung des parlaments grundsatz
einer jeden parlamentarischen demokratie
das bundesverfassungsgericht hat ganz
klar festgehalten als repräsentanten des
volkes müssen die gewählten abgeordneten
des deutschen bundestages die kontrolle
über grundlegende haushaltspolitische
entscheidungen behalten
der deutsche bundestag darf seine
budgetverantwortung nicht durch
unbestimmte haushaltspolitische
ermächtigungen auf andere akteure
übertragen so das
bundesverfassungsgericht sie haben aber
dennoch den rettungsschirm den
dauerhaften automatisierten
finanzierungsmechanismen zugestimmt und
sie bejubeln die pläne von präsident
manual makro kein widerspruch zum
gigantischen transfer von deutschen
steuergeld kein widerspruch zu einem
eu-finanzminister ganz im gegenteil es
scheint ihn nämlich nicht schnell genug
zugehen verantwortung nach paris und
brüssel zu übertragen und damit das
steuergeld dass sie viel
nie erarbeitet haben sehr geehrte damen
und herren unsere hauptseite sozial
gerecht behaupten sie tatsächlich
deutschland an einer der höchsten
einkommens und ausgaben belastung aller
westlichen staaten durch ihre absurde
steuerpolitik sind vor allem die
mittleren und kleinen einkommen vor
allem die familien belastet die
steuerzahler bluten zusätzlich mit dem
abschmelzen ihre ersparnisse für die
zinsersparnis die sich der staat über
die null und negativ zinspolitik der ezb
ermöglicht der start entschuldet sich
also auf kosten der sparer und
steuerzahler und dann über die schwarze
null reden was ist daran gerecht was ist
daran sozial sehr geehrte damen und
herren
und das ist nichts anderes als
steuerzahler ausbeutung nach
gutsherrenart was sie hier praktizieren
während die infrastruktur dieses landes
verfällt der staat seine bürger nicht
mehr schützen kann fließen aber
milliarden in die aufnahme und
alimentierung illegaler einwanderer und
in die sozialsysteme
und es ist erschreckend denn spätestens
20 jahren wird jeder fünfte rentner auf
die grundsicherung angewiesen sein
trotz eines harten arbeitsleben habe
heute unzählige senioren kaum genug zum
leben
zwei beispiele aus bochum zum einen
herbert w
bis mitte der 70er jahre unter tage
gearbeitet später bei opel hat viele
jahre ins deutsche rentensystem
eingezahlt sammelt am wochenende
flaschen vor dem ruhrstadion um seine
kümmerliche rente aufzubessern
zum anderen sahen die a ging früher auch
einer beschwerlichen arbeit nach
er war leibwächter von osama bin laden
hat nie ins deutsche sozialsystem
eingezahlt fährt am wochenende der mit
seinem moped ins grüne erhält vom staat
1200 euro pro monat und das seit sage
und schreibe zehn jahren und das ist aus
meiner sicht eine himmelschreiende
ungerechtigkeit die sie hier zu
verantworten haben sie behaupten der
haushalts zeit zukunftsorientiert im
gegenteil sie verbauen die chancen der
zukünftigen generation das fundament
unseres staates das sind die menschen
die hier leben und arbeiten es sind aber
nicht nur die menschen die jetzt hier
leben sondern auch die in zukunft hier
leben und ja wir haben die
hauptverantwortung für die menschen die
familien die schon länger hier leben und
diesen menschen haben sie zu dienen
staatsaufgabe ist nämlich dass über
generation aufgebaute volksvermögen
treuhänderisch zum wohle des deutschen
volkes zu verwalten und es nicht mit
vollen händen zum fenster
rauszuschmeißen denn eigentümer sind die
deutschen bürger und nicht sie nicht die
regierung seit 1972 werden in
deutschland jedes jahr weniger kinder
geboren als menschen sterben für die
überlebensfähigkeit eines
leistungsfähigen staates ist das ein
problem
was haben sie dagegen getan nichts naja
jedenfalls nichts wirksames denn sie
setzten ausschließen
oft kompensatorische einwanderung das
sagen sie ja die ganze zeit bei
muslimischen zuwanderern
schaut die geburtenrate nämlich ganz
anders aus sogar die ausschüttung der
einwohnerzahl durch zugewanderte
straftäter mit mehrfachen identitäten
scheint sie überhaupt gar nicht zu
stören doch ich kann ihnen sagen in
burkas kopftuchmädchen und alimentierte
messer männer und sonstige taugenichts
werden unseren wohlstand
das wird doch platz um vor allem den
sozialstaat nicht sicher dazu bedarf es
einer qualifizierten und herr kauder und
kölner plant und zügellosen
bildungsfernen zuwanderung und in
deutschland ich schon lange ein
grenzenloses einwanderungsland für
unqualifizierte und ein
auswanderungsland für hochqualifizierte
geworden und was tun sie dagegen wer
soll in zukunft für die renten aufkommen
wer zahlt denn ihre staatlichen pension
auch ihre hoheit schreihals ihre
eingefangen goldstücke etwa das glauben
sie im ernst wir bürger scheinen ihnen
vollkommen egal zu sein
sie wollen sich darauf beschränken den
niedergang unseres landes zu verwalten
ja teilweise kann man den eindruck ihn
sogar zu befeuern aber das wird wohl
ihren wertekanon entsprechen wenn eine
bundestags- vizepräsidentin hinter einem
transparentere transparenz her rennt
deutschlandtour miese stück scheiße und
alle dass hiermit tragen indem sie zum
bundestags viel zur präsidentin gewählt
wie claudia roth dann muss man sich über
nichts mehr wundern
hier in die
mond raus und die afd tritt hingegen für
verantwortung gerechtigkeit und für eine
lebenswerte zukunft ein deshalb fordern
die erstens einen schonungslosen
kassensturz alle zahlen müssen endlich
mal offen auf den tisch gelegt werden
wir fordern den sozialstaat endlich zu
sichern und die zukunft zu gestalten die
strategie des generation ersatzes durch
eine ungeregelte zuwanderung teilweise
aus frauenverachtenden stamms kulturen
hat sich als holzweg erwiesen wohlstand
kann nur gesichert werden wenn in
sichere grenzen und in die kommenden
generation investiert wird drittens
echte steuergerechtigkeit mittel um
geringverdiener müssen endlich ehrlich
belastet werden dazu muss der
grundfreibetrag endlich angehoben werden
2000 euro brutto im monat steuerfrei das
wäre doch mal visionär denn es kann doch
überhaupt gar nicht sein dass ein
facharbeiter bereits bei einem 1,3
fachen des durchschnittslohnes den
spitzensteuersatz zu zahlen hat und ich
kann ihnen sagen es ist endlich zahlt
jährliche entlastung keine weitere
aushöhlung der souveränität die hoheit
über unseren haushalt gehört nach berlin
und nicht nach brüssel und in diesem
sinne schließe ich mit einem zitat des
früheren tschechischen präsidenten
seemann dass ihn auch schon die
ehrenwerte ehemalige cdu-abgeordnete
erika steinbach vorgetragen hat ich
zitiere falls sie in einem land leben in
dem sie für das fischen ohne andersch 1
bestraft werden jedoch nicht für den
illegalen grenzübertritt ohne gültigen
reisepass dann haben sie das volle recht
zu sagen dieses land wird von idioten
begehrt
alles was hier als erste rednerin für
die größte oppositionsfraktion die afg
ich weiß nicht ob dies über die
mikrofone hören es gibt sogar im hirn
wolfgang schäuble jetzt der formulierung
unter anderem kopftuchmädchen und
sonstige taugenichts sie gebraucht damit
diskriminieren sie alle frauen die ein
kopftuch tragen dafür so wie sie zur
ordnung messer männer hatte sie auch
einige auszählungen drin
es gab hier boten voraus den anderen
fraktionen für den vortrag der
fraktionsvorsitzende der afg alles weil
ich das wort der bundeskanzlerin dr
angela merkel
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
guten morgen meine damen und herren ich
glaube es ist für jedermann erkennbar
dass der haushalt 2018 und die
dazugehörige mittelfristige
finanzplanung wieder sehr gute daten
aufweisen
das ist außerordentlich erfreulich wird
manchmal schon für selbstverständlich
inzwischen gehalten aber dass wir die
höchste beschäftigung seit der
wiedervereinigung haben dass wir seit
2014 keine neuen schulden machen
das ist alles andere als
selbstverständlich
wir werden im nächsten jahr erstmals
seit 2002 mit der gesamte verschuldung
wieder da liegen wo der europäische
stabilitätspakt und sinnvoll weiß
nämlich unterhalb von 60 prozent 2012
noch der internationalen finanz und
wirtschaftskrise lag die
gesamtverschuldung bei knapp 80 prozent
und dass wir das schaffen das ist nichts
anderes als generationengerechtigkeit
pur
und genau das denken an die die nach uns
heimatlos sein werden und leben werden
und deshalb ist das und der
internationale währungsfonds hat in
seinem gerade abgeschlossenen artikel 4
konsultationen mit deutschland geführt
hat die entwicklung der deutschen
volkswirtschaft als ich zitiere
beeindruckend bezeichnet fiskalischen
spielräume sollten genutzt werden um das
wachstumspotenzial zu erhöhen
staatliche investitionen in die
infrastruktur sorgt sollten getätigt
werden investitionen in bildung sollten
gestärkt werden verfahren sollten
beschleunigt werden und genau das ist
das was wir in unserem koalitionsvertrag
niedergelegt haben und was sich auch in
diesem haus zeit widerspiegelt das heißt
auch international findet das durchaus
unterstützen aber den kolleginnen und
kollegen
unabhängig von diesen guten zahlen und
werte erreichen uns täglich
beunruhigende nachrichten aus allen
teilen der welt leider auch austeilen
die sehr nahe an der europäischen union
liegen
die schrecklichen bilder aus syrien
inklusive von giftgas einsetzen in
jüngster zeit die kündigung des atomar
punkt mit dem rahmen durch
die vereinigten staaten von amerika die
bombardierung von stellungen auf den
golanhöhen durch den iran
ein drohender handelsstreit zwischen den
usa und der europäischen union
tägliche waffenstillstands verletzungen
an der kontakt linie in der ukraine
terroropfer auch am letzten wochenende
wieder in paris und in indonesien 70
jahre israel ein tag zum feiern und
trotzdem 59 tote palästinenser und viele
viele verwundete wir verfolgen diese
schlagzeilen täglich die uns vor augen
führen welche unruhiger und auch
unübersichtlicher welt geblieben und wir
wissen inzwischen dass wir uns von
diesen ereignissen nicht abkoppeln
nach dem arabischen frühling von vielen
auch als arabisches beben bezeichnet ist
die region für unsere haustür unruhig
geworden
der bürgerkrieg in syrien seit 2011 der
sturz von gaddafi in libyen mit dem
zerfall der staatlichen ordnung 2014 die
alexion der krim die probleme in der ost
ukraine 2014 der es in syrien und im
irak der völkermord an den juden und die
geplanten in rackern irak geplanten
attentate die paris mit charlie hebdo zu
erschüttern
das sicherheitspolitische umfeld und
sind unserer nachbarschaft hat sich
gravierend verändert das sind
tiefgreifende auswirkungen auch für uns
und sie zeigen uns noch einmal ein land
alleine kann mit sicherheit die
bekannten sicherheit sicherheit nicht
garantiert
und deshalb ist uns bewusst geworden was
wir vielleicht oft fast schon stereotyp
gesagt haben unsere sicherheit tech
unauflösbaren wenn der unserer
nachbarschaft zusammen deutschland
braucht für seine eigene minden
sicherheit eine einbindung in bündnisse
als mitglied der europäischen union und
als mitglied der nato und deshalb trotz
aller schwierigkeiten die wir in diesen
tagen haben sind und bleiben die
transatlantischen beziehungen von
herausragender bedeutung
das kleine konzert aber diese
transatlantischen beziehungen müssten
auch meinungsunterschiede aushalten auch
gerade in diesen tagen das zeigt sich
insbesondere an der kündigung des
iranischen staates durch die vereinigten
staaten von amerika wir haben über ein
jahrzehnt verhandelt um dieses abkommen
zustande zu bringen
dieses abkommen ist alles andere als
ideal
aber der iran hält sich nach allen
erkenntnissen der internationalen
atomenergiebehörde an die
verpflichtungen aus diesem abkommen
dieses abkommen ist interessiert wurden
einstimmig vom un-sicherheitsrat und
deshalb glauben wir großbritannien
frankreich deutschland aber mit uns auch
die mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
union dass es nicht richtig ist dieses
abkommen jetzt in dieser situation zu
können
das bedeutet nicht etwa dass wir mit dem
was der iran ansonsten tut zufrieden
sein
wir müssen über mehr sprechen über das
ballistische raketen verbraucht über den
einfluss den der iran die hisbollah im
süden über die über andere fragen aber
die frage die wir zu beantworten haben
und die wir so anders als die
vereinigten staaten von amerika
beantwortet haben heißt kann man besser
sprechen wenn man dieses abkommen
kündigt oder kann man besser sprechen
wenn man in diesem abkommen bleibt wir
glauben dass man deshalb miteinander
weiter reden kann und muss ich sage das
ausdrücklich weil das ballistisches
raketenprogramm eine gefährdung auch
gerade der sicherheit des platzes wir
glauben man kann besser sprechen wenn
man in diesem abkommen bleibt mit
genau diesem sinne hat der
bundesaußenminister gerade gestern abend
wieder gespräche geführt und wir wissen
auch dass zeigt sich jeden tag bringen
dann dass wir natürlich eine politische
lösung in syrien brauchen dass das leben
der menschen in syrien unter einem
unglaublichen schrecken es abläuft die
hälfte der bürgerinnen und bürger eines
landes wie syrien sind inzwischen auf
der flucht
ein großer teil innerhalb zu gehen ein
anderer teil außerhalb syriens
der kampf gegen die es ist vorangekommen
deutschland hat sich an der anti es
koalition an den operationen gegen das
beteiligt durch ausbildung der
peschmerga im irak und durch
luftüberwachung aber inzwischen ist aus
dem bürgerkrieg in syrien dem kampf
gegen den islamistischen terrorismus
ein regional konflikt gigantischen
ausmaßes geworden der ohne russland ohne
die türkei ohne den iran ohne saudi
arabien ohne jordanien und ich sage im
grunde auch ohne europa nicht zu lösen
ist aber war es auch und der
schriftsteller matthias in der gerade
von der konrad-adenauer-stiftung den
literaturpreis bekommen hat hat das
beklemmend
zu papier war es auch europa ist immer
sind betroffen und hat gleichzeitig
bisher zur politischen lösung dieses
konflikts nicht ausreichend beigetragen
sagt dass auch selbstkritisch und
deshalb sind wir froh dass wir jetzt mit
der neuen bundesregierung der so
genannten small group angehören in der
frankreich großbritannien deutschland
jordanien saudi arabien mit die usa
gemeinsam nach lösungen suchen und auf
der anderen seite muss natürlich dann
auch die so genannte astana gruppe
türkei iran und russland mit in die
gespräche einbezogen werden und das kann
bedeuten dass wir endlich auch die
arbeit des us vermittlers dem ist uhr ab
besser unterstützen können ich glaube
ist es alle mühe wert obwohl ich mir
keine illusionen machen über die
kompliziertheit des konflikts dass wir
politisch und stärker engagieren und das
wird die bundesregierung tun
und auch für einen anderen ort liegt in
unserer umgebung mit dem wir uns schon
viel beschäftigt haben den zwischen
russland und der ukraine gibt es nur
eine politische lösung die militärisch
ist das nicht zu lösen und wir tun das
in normandie format für versuchen den
das abkommen von minsk wieder zu beleben
obwohl es schon deprimierend ist dass es
jede nacht jede nacht zu
waffenstillstands verletzungen an der
kontakt linie kommt dass es immer wieder
behinderungen der osze beobachter gibt
die nicht im übrigen von dieser stelle
aus einmal herzlich danken möchte der
jahre über jahre erarbeitet und diese
arbeit mit
das sind 74 und deutschlands hat sich
immer und wir werden das verstärkt tun
und dass auch die neue bundesregierung
auch dem vernetzten ansatz verstehen wir
wissen wir können solche probleme nur
lösen indem wir entwicklung betreiben
indem wir politische lösungen suchen und
in dem wir auch als ultima ratio
militärische gewalt einsetzen aber
militärische gewalt allein das thema
nicht lösen und deshalb ist sozusagen
symptomatisch dafür in unserem
koalitionsvertrag vereinbar erhöhung von
entwicklungskosten und erhöhung der
verteidigungsausgaben eins zu eins um
deutlich zu machen dass uns dieser
vernetzte ansatz nicht irgendein
anliegen sondern ein zentrales anliegen
ist
aber wir müssen eben verpflichtungen auf
allen seiten einhalten und das heißt die
ob würde auf der einen seite die wir
noch nicht erreicht haben und das heißt
die ziele von wales der nato auf der
anderen seite diesen zielen fühlen wir
uns verpflichtet und das haben wir auch
im koalitionsvertrag niedergelegt
der bundesfinanzminister hat gestern
gesorgt mit seiner erlaubnis darf ich
ihn zitieren ein verteidigungs
politisches konzept wird nicht da nicht
nur dadurch gut das ist teuer ist doch
stimmt unbestritten aber die frage heißt
ja anders die frage heißt sie anders was
brauchen wir für eine bundeswehr die den
heutigen anforderungen rechnung
und wenn sie einmal und wenn sie einmal
vergleichen das weißbuch 2006 dass wir
auch schon einmal der großen koalition
verabschiedet haben in diesem weißbuch
war eine volle konzentration auf die
auslandseinsätze
damals gab der galt der satz von peter
struck in er richtig gesagt hat die
sicherheit deutschlands wird auch am
hindukusch und hindukusch steht fast
bedeutung verteidigt richtig glücklich
aber durch die ereignisse 2014 und durch
das was vor unserer haustür passiert
auch im raum syrien zb hat die nato 2014
beschlossen und wir haben das im übrigen
im weißbuch 2005 16
danach vollzog das neben den
auslandseinsätzen auch die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung wieder von größerer
bedeutung
und da kommt jetzt genau der punkt der
herausforderung von der bundesregierung
die bundeswehr gestellt ist die
bundesregierung natürlich auch nämlich
sicher zu stellen dass wir nicht nur
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten in den
auslandseinsätzen so ausrüsten und so
ausstatten dass sie ihre einsätze gut
absolvieren will sondern gleichermaßen
zu hause wegen der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung auch in viel
größerer breite material und ausrüstung
zur verfügung zu stellen um die
zusätzlichen aufgaben die wir heute
haben zu bewerkstelligen
und das ist die luftraumüberwachung
gewaltigen das ist die rückversicherung
für polen und die drei baltischen
staaten wo wir als rahmen nationen in
litauen tätig sind
das ist die verstärkung des chors in der
innenstädte
das sind engagements in rumänien und
bulgarien dazu muss ich schneller
truppen verlegen können damit dazu muss
ich noch nicht nur jeden hundertsten
soldaten sage ich mal gegriffen bin
keine expertin vernünftig ausstatten
können und alle anderen kommen mit wenig
übungsgerät aussagen
dazu muss ich in großer breite die
aufgaben und die ausrüstung schultern
und das ist die aufgabe vor der die
bundeswehr steht die zweite aufgabe ist
die die große herausforderung der
digitalisierung mit aufzunehmen
und da geht es einmal um die
digitalisierung der strukturen der
bundeswehr
aber da geht es fröhlich neue fähigkeit
nämlich die cyber fähigkeiten des sofas
richtig ein cyber kommando einzurichten
denn die hybride betriebsführung ist
teil der militärdoktrin zum beispiel
russlands ganz offiziell beschrieben
oder sind die knute da müssen wir
natürlich wehrhaft sein können ansonsten
werden deshalb geht es nicht um
aufrüstung sondern es geht ganz einfach
um ausrüstung
und ich finde darüber sollten wir einen
ruhigen dialog führen im übrigen mit dem
der beauftragten der das alles wunderbar
ausdrücken kann insbesondere in seinen
berichten und dann sollten wir einfach
helfen dass auch der wehrbeauftragte
wieder positive berichte sprechen meine
sammeln
das alles zeigt ja da zeigt sich da
zeigt sich ja dass wir natürlich unsere
außenpolitik auf multilateralismus
ausrichten der multilateralismus steht
im augenblick unter großem druck und
dafür wissen weil der multilateralismus
unter so großem druck steht dass europa
sein eigenes schicksal stärker in die
eigene hand nehmen muss als das bislang
der fall war und deshalb brauchen wir
europäische antworten und es war eine
gute nachricht dass in sehr kurzer zeit
nach dem schock den wir hatten als
großbritannien beschlossen hat aus der
europäischen union auszutreten wir als
erstes mal ein jahrzehntelang hundes
projekt auf die beine gebracht haben
nämlich eine europäische verteidigung
die union eine strukturierte
zusammenarbeit
diese strukturierte zusammenarbeit hat
jetzt erste projekte in denen
deutschland im übrigen in einigen dieser
projekte auch verantwortung übernimmt
aber die wichtige botschaft ist
eigentlich eine andere wenn sie sich die
zahl der waffensysteme der europäischen
union der mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union anschauen dann kommen
wir auf stolze 178 wenn sich die zahl
der arten von waffensystemen der
vereinigten staaten von amerika angucken
dann kommen die auf 30
die geben 3,4 prozent ihres
bruttoinlandsprodukts für verteidigung
aus die europäische union liegt im
mittel unter zwei prozent und mit 178
waffensystemen können sie überhaupt
nicht effizient sein das heißt der große
nutzen auf die lange zeit wird darin
bestehen auch mit einheitlich
system viel effizienter in der
ausbildung auch viel einfacher
miteinander agieren zu können und das
ist allemal richtig und einen
riesenfortschritt der einen neuen
pfeiler auf der europäischen
zusammenhalt der zweite die zweite große
aufgabe europa zu schultern hat das ist
die auch frage wie regeln und steuern
wie immigration und das wird ein thema
sein das uns über jahre
ich sage jahrzehnte beschäftigen mit der
nachbarschaft syrien aber vor allen
dingen dann auch mit der nachbarschaft
afrika und deshalb ist es richtig dass
wir an einem gemeinsamen europäischen
asylsystem arbeiten deshalb war es
richtig rund 6 einzuführen aber mit 600
polizisten bei frontex werden sie die
außengrenzen der europäischen union mit
sicherheit nicht schützen können deshalb
ist eine der großen aufgaben der zukunft
frontex zu stärken und vernünftig
auszurüsten und deutschland wird dazu
seinen beitrag leisten
und gewissen auf abschottung alleine
wird nicht helfen wenn wir nicht auch
ursachen von flucht und vertreibung
bekämpfen ich habe über die politische
lösung in syrien gesprochen über den
kampf gegen den jetzt in ihrer und die
große aufgabe
gerhard müller würde das jetzt den
marshallplan für afrika nennen was ich
unterstütze große aufgabe heißt hier
auch wieder in einer gemeinsamen
europäischen kraft anstrengend denn
unsere europäische entwicklungspolitik
ist nicht immer effizient wirklich auch
zur entwicklung von afrika beizutragen
und das hat zwei komponenten die eine
komponente ist die humanitäre wir haben
das erlebt als die flüchtlinge in
jordanien und libanon kein geld mehr
hatten um lebensmittel zu haben um ihre
kinder zu beschulen
da haben war der druck zu fliehen ins
unermessliche gewachsen
aber wenn sie sich heute die budgets der
un hilfsorganisationen anschauen dann
ist die wahrheit obwohl wir ein
vielfaches mehr tun ist internationalen
längst nicht mehr getan nicht so viel
getan sie sein müssten alle budgets
autoren hat sehr oft
welternährungsprogramm sind dramatisch
defizitär
und wir müssen unsere stimme wo immer
das geht erheben und natürlich auch
unseren beitrag leisten für diese
aber es gab natürlich jetzt auch nicht
so sein dass wir die gesamte
entwicklungsetat sozusagen eine
humanitäre hilfe um wenden weil
entwicklung ja nicht ausreichend
stattfinden und dann ist es auch richtig
dass wir uns fragen sind unsere mittel
und methoden der entwicklungshilfe
eigentlich ausreichend ich sage nein die
klassische entwicklungshilfe alleine
reicht nicht aus wir müssen überlegen
wie wir wirtschaftlichen schwung in die
dinge bringen wie wir auch mit
kreditinstrumente termes und vielem
anderen mehr noch mehr investitionen in
afrika möglich machen aber natürlich
auch durch das was wolfgang schäuble g20
präsidentschaft gemacht hat durch
bessere rahmenbedingungen kommt access
afrika ein gutes investitionsumfeld
anders wird wirtschaftliche entwicklung
dort nicht in gang kommen nur mit
staatlichen geldern wird das nicht
klappen
[Applaus]
und natürlich brauchen der drittens in
europa eine stärkung der wirtschafts und
währungsunion
wir sind durch die krise gekommen wir
haben das heute eine situation in der
alle europäischen mitgliedsstaaten die
den euro haben wieder wachsen
die beschäftigung steigt aber das kann
es sich zufrieden stellen weil wir
natürlich wissen dass im augenblick auch
die europäische zentralbank eine politik
wird die nicht auf dauer so weitergehen
wird und deshalb ist die aufgabe die
eurozone nachhaltig zu stärken und
krisenfest zu machen
das ist darüber intensive diskussionen
gibt und dass wir darüber sprechen was
ist die nationale verantwortlichkeit
viele der politiken in europa sind nicht
vergemeinschaftet wir können alleine
kein handelsabkommen mehr abschließen
aber wir können natürlich alleine
arbeitsmarktpolitik machen jeder hat
internationaler verantwortung die
budgethoheit das in nationaler
verantwortung die frage der
wettbewerbsfähigkeit der genehmigung ist
in vielen bereichen nicht in allen
vieles ist euro bestellt ist aber in
nationaler verantwortung und deshalb
liegt zuallererst natürlich die aufgabe
zu hause in den einzelnen
mitgliedstaaten dazu beizutragen dass
die wettbewerbsfähigkeit des wirkt und
zwar nicht besser gegenüber unserem
europäischen durchschnitt sondern besser
gegenüber dem was global notwendig ist
aber dann ist es eben so dass die
globale sicht auf gemeinsame
währungsunionen so ist was man sagt wir
müssen auch irgendwo letztverantwortung
haben wir wollen wissen ob ihr alle
gemeinsam zum euro steht und deshalb ist
es richtig und gut steht esm
weiterzuentwickeln
aber auch aufgaben zu geben in richtung
des bbi eines internationalen
währungsfonds das können wir allein und
deshalb stehe ich auch zu dass wenn die
risiko der risikoabbau national weit
voran gegangen ist wir einen komplex pop
haben und dieser kommen texdorf auch
beim esm angesiedelt sein könnte
so wie der bundesfinanzministers gestern
gesagt und dann hat haben wir die
aufgabe natürlich auch zu überlegen wie
können wir die konvergenz der eurozone
und die stabilität der eurozone sicher
stellen
und da finden im augenblick gesprächen
statt denn wir haben ja im augenblick
zwei projekte das eine projekt ist
eurozone auch finanzielle ausstattung
meinetwegen investitionshaushalt weil
ähnliches wie wir es in unserer
koalitionsvereinbarung geschrieben haben
aber gleichzeitig haben wir die beratung
unserer mittelfristigen finanziellen
vorausschau euro
und jetzt sagen sie mal der
finanzminister ist brust
aber irgendwie gelten auch für ihn die
grundrechenarten das heißt deutlich mehr
in den europäischen haushalt und
deutlich mehr noch in den euro optionen
haushalt und trotzdem noch die
stabilitätskriterien einheiten ist
natürlich nicht ganz einfach
und deshalb werden wir mit frankreich
genau auch über diese wechselwirkungen
sprechen was müssen wir in den haushalt
packen denn nach dem austritt
großbritannien sind 85 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts der europäischen
union eurozone und was müssen wir
speziell als absicherung gegebenenfalls
noch im bürgerhaus wettmachen und diese
gespräche finden statt und wir werden
bis zum juni rat darüber auch
einvernehmen erzielen das ist im übrigen
eigentlich die einzige noch richtig
offene frage unter all den vorschlägen
die gemacht wurden also ich glaube wir
sind schon ganz schön weit vorangebracht
und dann meine damen und herren liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen geht es
natürlich auch um die erweiterung hier
geht es im wesentlichen um die frage wie
geht es weiter mit dem westlichen balkan
nicht wert heute noch so fliegen
wir werden uns morgen mit den
mitgliedstaaten des westlichen balkans
treffen und dass sie die europäische
perspektive haben das ist ja
unbestritten
und jetzt ist die frage wie und unter
welchen bedingungen können wir das
machen aber ich kann nur sagen der
westliche balkan und die situation dort
entscheidet über krieg und frieden in
unserer absoluten nachbarschaft und wenn
sie sehen wie schnell da die funken
sozusagen hoch schlagen zwischen serbien
und kosovo zwischen serbien und bosnien
halboth von bosnien und herzegowina
wie schwierig das ist die namensfrage
von mazedonien zu klären wie man ringt
um die grenzabkommen kosovo hat jetzt
mit montenegro interimsabkommen
geschlossen ein riesenerfolg wenn man
sich vor augen führt dass selbst
zwischen slowenien und kroatien heute
noch keine klarheit über die
sie zugang ist obwohl kroatien mitglied
der europäischen union ist uns nur
wenigen mitglied der europäischen union
ist im übrigen wieder einen grund zu
sagen bevor er nicht grenzfragen geklärt
sind niemals eintritt eines landes muss
ich sagen gerückt und deshalb ist es so
wichtig dass wir uns im diese fragen
kümmern und hier auch zur
wirtschaftlichen stärkung beitrag also
meine damen und herren alles wichtig für
europa und um unser wohlstand
versprechenden europa einzuhalten geht
es natürlich jetzt auch um die schaffung
eines digitalen binnenmarktes eine
unzahl von verordnungen und die wir
umsetzen oder noch verhandeln müssen
hier geht's sehr stark auch um die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit europas und deshalb
geht es hier auch sehr stark um die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit deutschlands und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich habe
es schon oft gesagt ich sage es heute
wieder
vielleicht ist das ambitionierteste
projekt weil wir ganz neu zum teil
denken müssen die frage wie gestalten
wir diesen umfassenden
gesellschaftlichen wandel der mit der
digitalisierung verbunden ist
das ist ja nicht nur dass wir die
infrastruktur ausbauen müssen das müssen
wir auch da können wir auch besser
werden
und eines tages muss die app wieder
abgeschafft werden wenn der mann die
funklöcher der bundesnetzagentur
mitteilt allerdings zu glauben anhalt
sie den telekommunikationsanbieter mit
ist nicht so sehr erfolgsversprechend
weil sie damit noch nicht wechseln
sondern die braucht man immer druck und
natürlich müssen wir nach der tatsache
dass wir uns jetzt auf den 50 megabit
pro sekunde ausbau konzentriert haben
jetzt in zukunft nur noch
breitbandanschlüsse also glasfaser oder
wir fördern das ist klar und dazu haben
wir auch die entsprechenden programme
dazu haben wir die vorhaben da hat der
bundesfinanzminister gesagt dass
zusätzliche mittel jetzt auch in einen
digital france kommen damit wir anfangen
können und nicht wieder zwei jahre
warten bevor es endlich mal losgeht und
die ausschreibung müssen auch so sein
dass die leute vor ort nutzen können und
nicht
kräftig nicht braucht das haben sie
daran aber das geht ja weiter
es geht um forschung und entwicklung wir
zählen zu den fünf ländern die am
meisten für forschung und entwicklung
ausgeben aber es ist richtig dass wir
uns vorgenommen haben den anteil der
heute bei 2,4 und 90 prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts nicht auf 3,5
prozent im jahre 2025 zu erhöhen weil es
heute länder gibt die bereits diese 3,5
prozent haben und da ist es natürlich
von entscheidender bedeutung dass wir
insbesondere im industriellen bereich
insbesondere im mobilitätsbereich weil
der digitalisierung vorne mit bei der
konsumenten digitalisierung haben wir
den anschluss jahr verloren dann nutzen
wir alle asiatische oder amerikanische
geräte daran haben wir uns gewöhnt okay
das werden wir auch so schnell nicht
aufholen aber jetzt lässt um unsere
industriellen grundlagen geht um das
internet der dinge wo wir das land sind
das noch eine hohe industrielle
wertschöpfung hat da müssen wir vorne
mit dabei sein da reicht platz fünf und
platz sechs und sonst was nicht aus
sonst werden wir kein führende sind das
kinder
bei der mobilität die mobilität wird
sich dramatisch verändern
und deshalb ist es natürlich nicht nur
zu kritisieren sondern eigentlich
unfassbar sage ich mal
welches vertrauen die deutsche
automobilindustrie im zusammenhang mit
den diesel verspielt aber es kann jetzt
nicht unsere aufgabe sein das ist unsere
aufgabe der industrie zu sagen ihr müsst
verloren gegangenes vertrauen selber
wieder gut machen das ist nicht die
aufgabe der bild aber ich sage auch das
kann auch nicht unserer interesse sein
dass wir durch politische maßnahmen
anschließend die automobilindustrie so
schwächen dass sie keine kraft mehr hat
in die eigentlichen
zukunftsinvestitionen etwas
hineinzustecken
und das ist die auseinandersetzung diese
jetzt führen zum beispiel die gutachter
liegen jetzt auf dem tisch die müssen
wir beobachtet werden dann werden wir
auch die kommunen wieder einladen dann
wird das diesem forum tagen aber meine
damen und herren tausende von euro jetzt
kann als 3000 2000 oder 5000 sind und
zwei bis drei jahre beschäftigung aller
ingenieure mit der frage wie man dann
wieder die typen zulassung kriegt weil
man an die mutter was geändert hat ist
dass die richtige beschäftigung für die
automobilindustrie müssen wir nicht alle
kräfte zusammen lebt und dauert
immobilien ist die sagen ihr müsst jetzt
in die mobilität der zukunft investieren
ins autonome fahren in alternative
antriebe und da unterstützen wir euch
dabei
und da gibt es für mich ein punkt der
treibt mich um seit jahren ich bin froh
dass da ein umdenken jetzt bei der
wirtschaft stattfindet nämlich die
tatsache dass behauptet wird die
batterie zellproduktion die können wir
in europa nicht mehr
ich sage ihnen wenn ein auto der zukunft
sehen wir mal an die elektromobilität
ist dieses die antriebstechnologie der
zukunft was nicht sicher ist besteht zu
40 prozent aus wertschöpfung in einer
batterie und dann noch mal 20 bis 30
prozent aus digitaler wertschöpfung der
eine teil kommt dann aus amerika oder
asien der andere teil kommt auch
definitiv aus asien bei der batterien
was ist dadurch die wertschöpfung die
wir hier in europa
und deshalb sage ich wir brauchen eine
strukturierte förderung die europäische
kommission sieht solche möglichkeiten
vor wir machen das jetzt schon bei chips
mit der eine kraftanstrengung machen
auch in die zellproduktion einzusteigen
nur ohne wirtschaftlichen druck und
wirtschaftliche mitmacher geht das
natürlich nicht das können wir als staat
machen und deshalb bin ich dankbar dass
einigen automobilindustrie darum denken
wir werden das unterstützen
und wir brauchen die konsequente
digitalisierung von verwaltung und im
übrigen kompatibel mit der gesundheit
kaufen sage ich dem geburtstagskind
jetzt sparen heute man habe heute
geburtstag und die brauchen einen zugang
der bürgerinnen und bürger für alle
verwaltungsleistungen und das wird ein
große kraftanstrengungen natürlich sein
wir brauchen eine nationale
bildungsoffensive sowohl digital packt
schule als auch im bereich der
weiterbildung der arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer denn die veränderungen die
jetzt statt für im technischen bereich
diese veränderungen haben natürlich
massive ausdrücken auf das was in
zukunft gebraucht wird und wir haben
heute schon einen großen
fachkräftebedarf den wir befriedigen
müssen und deshalb ist es richtig dass
wir einen fachkräfte zuwanderungsgesetz
machen der der wirtschaft stärken wollen
dann kann es sein das hängt gar nicht
mehr im augenblick an den hohen
sozialabgaben oder in der steuerfrage es
hängt daran dass sie einfach in
deutschland niemand mehr inne
und da müssen wir helfen dass die
wirtschaft in deutschland bleiben kann
und hier wertschöpfung betreibt und
nicht irgendwo weg gehen muss weil sie
hier keine fachkräfte finden deshalb ist
das die richtige
meine damen und herren für uns und das
wird noch eine riesen anstrengend ich
bin im übrigen sehr dankbar dass die
koalitionsfraktionen sich entschieden
haben zwei enquete kommissionen die im
zusammenhang mit der digitalisierung
stehen zu beschließen
einmal mit der künstlichen intelligenz
meine damen und herren wir sind seit 20
30 jahren relativ gut dabei was
künstliche intelligenz anbelange aber
jetzt sind wir gerade in einer situation
wo wir den anschluss ein biss
vielleicht schon verloren haben oder zu
verlieren drohen warum bei plötzlich
zwei entwicklungen zusammen kommen die
künstliche intelligenz entwicklung
algorithmen oder ähnliches als solches
plus die fähigkeit riesige mengen an
daten zu farbe und jetzt ist dass bei
der künstlichen intelligenz so die
entwickelt sich nur gut wenn sie viele
breite datenmengen verarbeiten und bei
den datenmengen ist natürlich die frage
wir reden gerade über die einführung der
datenschutz grund verordnung wie
garantieren wir mit den daten und wie
stellen wir viele im übrigen oft
anonymisierte daten zur verfügung
aber zu glauben wir könnten bei der
künstlichen intelligenz vorne sein und
bei daten so zu sagen so restriktiv wie
möglich ist genauso wie wenn man kühe zu
züchten will und ihnen kein futter gibt
es ist einfach so
und deshalb ist die kommission ethik der
daten wichtig aber sie darf nicht so
enden dass daten sozusagen zu bewahren
gut gemacht werden sondern aus daten
kann man neue produkte erzielen und die
tatsache dass daten sozusagen ein
wichtiger faktor in der sozialen
marktwirtschaft werden wird air marin
ist ein bisschen unruhig wenn jemandes
ford-sprecher ich meine das ziemlich
ernst die tatsache dass daten ein so
wichtiger faktor einer sozialen
marktwirtschaftlichen bedeutet im grunde
dass wir neue decken müssen vom
steuersystem bis zu den sozialen
sicherungssystemen wir erleben das jetzt
an folgendem natürlich ist das nicht in
ordnung dass google amazon facebook und
wie sie alle heißen kaffee wie man so
schön sagt keine steuern in europa
zahlen
aber jetzt zu sagen was man auch jetzt
erfinden einfach eine virtuelle
betriebsstätte und die besteuerung wäre
also erst noch richtig betriebsstätte
wozu wird das führen wir sind einer der
großen exportnation
dann werden die die die betriebsstätten
irgendwo in china oder sonst wo die
deutschen unternehmen dann werden die
heimatländer
das sind jetzt richtig betriebsstätten
jetzt besteuert verdi auch deshalb sind
sie zögerlich zu bestimmten vorschlägen
gemacht werden
nicht weil ich finde dass man steuern
zahlen muss aber wenn ich hier ein
unternehmen steuerlich habe dergestalt
altes körperschaftsteuer recht und da
habe ich eine besteuerung der
internetkonzerne und anschließend weiß
ich nicht mehr ob das auto ein rollendes
internet ist oder ob das auto noch in
die alte körperschaftsteuer gehört da
muss sich steuersysteme finden die
miteinander kompatibel sind und deshalb
sind die arbeiten der oecd so wichtig
und deshalb können wir da jetzt nicht
einfach mal so schlapp machen und sagen
für zwei jahre probieren wir mal das
grausam ist es vernünftig durchdenken
das heißt aber nicht dass wir nichts tun
und ehrlich wird es sein dass ob daten
auch wert haben wie arbeit und ähnliches
darüber müssen wir dringend diskutieren
und vielleicht können wir dazu ja auch
die entsprechenden fachleute eine
allgemein sagen kann ich habe so lange
über digitalisierung gesprochen weil ich
glaube dass davon der wohlstand des
wohlstands versprechen und wenn wir uns
unsere koalitionsvereinbarung anschauen
und das spiegelt sich alles im haushalt
wider
dann sind wir ja in dieser richtung
wirklich gut vorangegangen
wir haben einen digital kabinett jetzt
das wird vor der sommerpause tagen
wir werden einen digital rat einreden
einrichten der uns ganz spezifisch berät
über dinge die wir noch nicht so wissen
über entwicklungen die wir haben
wir haben die digitale kooperation
zwischen den ressorts der
bundesregierung verbessert auch durch
die staatsministerin für digitalisierung
im kanzleramt und bei der die bei dem
digital kabinett kommt übrigens raus
jeder minister ist heute in bestimmter
weise in digital minister das durchzieht
alle bereiche der gesellschaft und
deshalb werden wir darauf zusammen
arbeiten und ich werde auch demnächst
eine anhörung zur künstlichen
intelligenz einladen damit wir hier
nochmal fest schreiben wo stehen wir und
damit wir vor allen dingen auch sagen
können was fehlt und wo muss ich ja
besser zusammenarbeiten im übrigen
klassisches produkt für deutsch
französische kooperation so haben was ja
auch in unserer koalitionsvereinbarung
verabredet und frankreich und
deutschland werden heute in sofia beim
abendessen wo wir über innovation
sprechen einen vorschlag machen wie wir
auch mit disruptiven innovationen in
europa umgehen stichwort dabei auch
sowas braucht europa und das muss
gemeinsam gemacht werden im moment haben
haben wir unsere koalitionsvereinbarung
aber auch in einer stimmung
verabschiedet die uns sagt wie stimmung
war ich nicht war der lage entsprechend
aber wie war der ernsthaftigkeit der
lage geschuldet sagen wir mal so sie
können darauf auf gewissen vorarbeiten
aufbauen obwohl wir das nie eingestanden
haben egal jedenfalls jedenfalls hat uns
angetrieben dass die bürgerinnen und
bürger in deutschland das leben aus der
perspektive betrachten wie stellt sich
das für mich da und nicht aus der
perspektive betrachten wer ist gerade
für was zuständig und deshalb sind wir
an einigen stellen bei uns
hinausgewachsen sage ich jetzt mal als
cdu-mitglied wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit schulen zu fördern nicht nur
in finanzschwachen kommunen
wir haben gesagt wer den sozialen
wohnungsbau oder wir arbeiten daran und
hoffen auf tätige mithilfe
wir haben die wir wissen auch dass wir
diese mit hilfe brauchen
wir haben uns entschlossen mehr für den
sozialen wohnungsbau zu tun
wir haben uns entschlossen mehr für die
gemeinde verkehrsfinanzierung zu tun
alles mit grundgesetzänderungen
verwundung und liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist für den bund schon
nicht so eine triviale entscheidung denn
in der kombination mit dem bund
länderfinanzausgleich der in dieser
legislaturperiode 2020 in kraft tritt
schlecht der bund damit auch seine
finanziellen möglichkeiten und olaf
scholz hat doch gestern richtig darauf
hingewiesen wenn wir den sozialen
wohnungsbau die länder gehen wenn der
bund mehr in die bund- länder-
finanzverhandlungen gibt wenn denn die
meine verkehrs finanzierungsgesetz fehlt
bei den ländern ist dann zu sagen wenn
die investitionssumme im bund genau um
diesen teil auch sich verschmälert zu
sagen ja nun investiert der bund nicht
mehr so können wir die sachen nicht
machen wir haben gesagt vergebens da hin
wo am besten mit den dingen gearbeitet
werden kann es dort dann aber nicht als
erstes 14 tage später vergessen
und trotzdem investieren werden wir
investieren übrigens nicht nur
steuergelder so wir werden die
versteigerung der 5g frequenzen haben
wir werden daraus etwas machen und unser
problem ist im raum nicht dass wir zu
wenig geld für investitionen haben unser
problem ist eine baufirma zu finden und
die genehmigungen zu haben und deshalb
müssen wir genehmigungsrecht
beschleunigen und versuchen wir
zu haben damit wir da vorankommen und da
ist es richtig die aber zu machen
vor bereits das baukindergeld ich das
alles sind incentives immer nur zu sagt
anreize um besser zu leben
ja die letzten jahr haben wir schon viel
gemacht aber noch nicht genug so ist das
leben
sonst hätten wir ja wissen wir
irgendwann aufhören abgeordnete zu sein
politik wird immer wieder neue aufgaben
haben das ist das schöne und das was
spannendes meine damen und herren der
riesen bereich der sicherheit ist für
uns wichtig auch hier werden der
kooperation haben pakt für den
rechtsstaat überhaupt nicht denkbar weil
man nicht mit kommunen und ländern
zusammen arbeitet das heißt die ganze
koalition es angelegt auf ein sehr
kooperatives verhalten des gesamten
föderalen systems und ich setze darauf
dass das was wir einen geldern
ausgegeben haben wir bestimmte zwecke
von den ländern kommunen dann auch
wirklich für diese zwecke verwendet wird
und da wären wir schon sehr darauf
achten dass das nicht irgendwo
verschwinden
meine damen und herren 1 ließen gleich
neben der sicherheit ist natürlich auch
die steuerung und ordnung der migration
im innern
deshalb haben wir uns für diese für die
anker zentren und ich finde ich jetzt
sollten auch alle dazu stehen und die
vorschläge des bundesinnenministers an
dieser stelle sind wirklich sehr
praxisnah und mit verlaub ich muss man
ehrlich sagen wenn man am 19 april und
wir sind noch nicht mal 100 tagen im amt
etwas hört über missstände im amt die
missstände sind nun zu sagen der
minister hat die sache nicht im griff
als damals recht sagen dass auch ein
bisschen komisch und da
koalitionskreisen hält sich das noch
einmal angemerkt
wir orientieren die sozialen zukunft
systeme auf die sozialen
sicherungssysteme auf die zukunft
gestern die renten kommission eingesetzt
das wird ein hartes stück arbeit und wir
werden natürlich im pflege und
gesundheit riesen kraftanstrengung
machen mehr fachkräfte auch hier wieder
ein riesen problem und ich glaube wir
alle sind im übrigen uns einig und es
war es in weiten teilen eine
länderkompetenz dass man in den pflege
ausbildungsberufen bis vor kurzem
schulgeld gezahlt hat und keine
ausbildungsvergütung das gehört zu den
anachronismen der bundesrepublik
deutschland und das dann das kurz bevor
die republik 70 doch darüber bin ich
sehr
und es geht darum die natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen zu sichern
klimaschutz wir werden eine kommission
haben die sich mit dem ausstieg aus der
braunkohle befasst sie erinnern sich vor
mehr als zehn jahren haben wir mit
unserem dem ausstieg aus der steinkohle
befasst wir haben das so hinbekommen
dass dieses jahr die letzte grube
schließt aber die menschen die dort
gearbeitet haben diesen wechsel auch
verkraften konnten und er mit ihnen
gestaltet wurde
und so muss es auch bei der braunkohle
seien erst fragen was wird in der region
und dann aussteigen und nicht erst
aussteigen daten festlegen und dann sich
überlegen was wird aus dem menschen zur
umkehr und wir werden uns auch an eine
lebenswerte umwelt auf eine lebenswerte
umwelt auch mehr tempo mehr vernünftige
landwirtschaft ich hoffe nur dass die
europäische union auch in der lage ist
gibt es bürokratisierung der zweiten
säule die sich an diesem thema widmet
auch mal hinzukriegen ansonsten werde
man das nicht schaffen und ich will mit
etwas schließen was vielleicht manchmal
ein bisschen klein vorkommen da was ganz
großes
zum zwanzigsten mal nächste woche wird
zum ersten mal der tag der welt bienen
tag sein und die bienen stehen
inzwischen pars pro toto im übrigen eine
initiative von slowenischen imkern die
biene stehen inzwischen pars pro toto
für das was wir unter artenvielfalt und
das natur wie sie funktionieren muss und
soll und wie wir sie schützen müssen
steht und derzeit sollten wir an diesem
tag wirklich an diese artenvielfalt
denken und etwas gutes für die winkel in
deutschland
klöckner und der slowenische
agrarminister haben hierzu eine
vereinbarung geschlossen wie wir
zusammenarbeiten gerade mit slowenien
ein kleines teilchen eines guten ganz
präzisen konkreten einsatz weil damit
haben sie sehen wir haben viel arbeit
wir wollen dass auch die bundesregierung
wird mit nachdruck arbeiten herzlichen
dank alles gute am zwanzigsten mal sein
dass wir ihn tag und die bundeskanzlerin
heute sehr aufgeräumt hat nur selten aus
blatt geschaut hat hier die große
weltpolitik erklärt und endete dann bei
den bienen interessant auch wenn man sie
länger beobachtet hat die jahre über
durchaus sehr kritische passagen auch in
richtung koalitionspartner spd zum
beispiel stellte sich bei der frage wann
für klar vor dem bundesinnenminister und
rügte die sozialdemokratin ihm gesagt
der mann das niemals 100 tage im amt und
flügel verfehlungen die isda
zweifelsohne markt kann ja nix dass dann
die transatlantische beziehung damit
fingen die bundeskanzlerin an und sagte
diese sind von herausragender bedeutung
wenngleich sie auch im moment ein
bisschen einem misslichen licht
erscheinen
aber sie hat noch einmal deutlich
gemacht an der seite amerikas steht
deutschland selbstverständlich anders
ist das bei dem iran abkommen
da werden die europäer darum kämpfen
dass dieses abkommen bestehen bleibt ich
bezweifle nur dass das von erfolg
gekrönt ist aber noch ist da ja nicht
das letzte wort gesprochen jedenfalls
hat sie dann auch mal ein schwert europa
und die entwicklung europas gesetzt vor
allen dingen dort auch auf die migration
nächster redner christian lindner der
partei- und fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp
herr präsident lieber kolleginnen und
kollegen frau kollegin dr weil sie haben
hier heute nach afd manier wieder allen
anderen zensuren erteilt und ist ja auch
ihr gutes recht als oppositionsfraktion
das zu tun aber eine fraktion eine
partei in der sich der national
ökonomische und der sozialen nationale
flügel sich nicht auf ein eigenes
rentenkonzept einigen kann eine solche
partei sollte erst mal sich selbst an
erklärung unterziehen bevor sie über
andere urteilen dann können sie wieder
kommen dann können sie wiederkommen frau
bundeskanzlerin in ihrer koalition wird
gestritten der gesundheitsminister und
der arbeitsminister streiten über hartz4
der wirtschaftsminister bemüht sich
darum dass die nord stream zwei parteien
kommt der außenminister verweigert sie
allen zusätzlichen dialog initiativen
mit russland ist ungeklärt ob man auch
was um dieser regierung der islam zu
deutschland gehört
oder nicht frau nahles ermahnt sieht die
brücken teilzeit müsse jetzt aber auch
wirklich kommen und wir haben gestern
und heute auf offener bühne eine
auseinandersetzung um den wert erlebt
sie haben bei der bundeswehrtagung 1,5
prozent investitionen in die
verteidigung gemessen am
bruttoinlandsprodukt 2025 zugesagt frau
von der leyen fordert zwölf milliarden
euro zusätzlich für die
legislaturperiode
und dann stellt sich der
bundesfinanzminister hin und sagt ein
verteidigungs politisches konzept wird
nicht besser dadurch dass es teuer ist
sie haben ihn heute hier in die
schranken verwiesen aber ausweislich der
zahlen des haushalts ändert sich nicht
und sie gibt keinen mittel aufwuchs frau
bundeskanzlerin sie sprechen dieser tage
oft von der krise des multilateralismus
mit blick auf die drei
regierungsparteien bekommt dieses wort
eine ganz andere bedeutung die
sozialdemokratische fraktion überredet
keinen beifall gespendet und wir
ermuntern sie herr bundeskanzler
wir ermuntern sie bei diesen offenen
richtungsfrage von ihrer
richtlinienkompetenz gebrauch zu machen
führen sie führen sie dieses land und
lassen sie lassen sie worten taten
folgen
sie haben hier plädiert für eine
stärkung des transatlantischen
verhältnisses
dabei haben sie unsere unsere
unterstützung
also sollte der deutsche bundestag das
freihandelsabkommen mit kanada endlich
nach defizit ein klares signal für das
worauf warten sie worauf warten sie
wir brauchen europa angesichts der
kündigung des iran abkommens durch die
usa
der lage in syrien und einer im raum
stehenden auseinandersetzung in
handelsfragen
aber wie tritt europa auf der weltbühne
auf binnen einer woche kommt der
amerikanische präsident nach washington
und die deutsche bundeskanzlerin der
eine drei tage mit militärischen ehren
die andere drei stunden bei wasser und
brot
der französische wirtschaftsminister
sagt wir schützen unsere französische
wirtschaft vor sanktionen
der deutsche wirtschaftsminister sagt
wir können das nicht
wir wünschen uns eine abgestimmte
europäische haltung frau bundeskanzlerin
es ist zeit für einen eu sondergipfel zu
diesen fragen damit wir auch der welt
sind wohl unterstreichen dafür an einem
strang
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben eine neue
gelegenheit verstreichen lassen
deutschland klar in fragen der
weiterentwicklung europas zu
positionieren
auch der bundesfinanzminister hat ja
dieses thema gestern aufgemacht
die süddeutsche zeitung jubelt heute er
habe ein leidenschaftliches plädoyer für
europa gehalten
alle die dabei waren müssen sagen
offensichtlich gibt es eine gewissene
öffentliche entwöhnung in fragen der
leidenschaft wenn der auftritt von olaf
scholz in der europa-politik bereits den
affekt stau löst vielleicht liegt auch
vielleicht vielleicht liegt in wahrheit
auch die frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
näher an der wahrheit die nämlich
geurteilt und kommentiert hat dass der
finanzminister sich nach und nach aus
dem herausfinden will was die spd zuvor
in den koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hat
unter dem strich kann man sagen keine
klare position dieser bundesregierung
einer solchen existenzfrage und jobs
dort wo es dann klare aussagen ergeben
hat passen sie ausgerechnet nicht zur
zeit ausgerechnet über europäische
währungsfonds sprechen sie
und ausgerechnet über den kamen wächst
ob oder wir drücken uns mal auf deutsch
aus die letzte
die linie mit auch dem geld deutscher
steuerzahler bei der abwicklung maroder
privater banken
und dann sagen sie werter herr
finanzminister ja sie hätten die
vermutungen könnte bei der reduzierung
von risiken vielleicht noch schneller
vorankommen als man denkt was bringt sie
zu diesem optimismus
ich lese dass in italien eine koalition
davor steht in die regierung zu kommen
die flatex und bedingungsloses
grundeinkommen gleichzeitig will und die
einen schuldenerlass von 250 milliarden
euro bei der europäischen zentralbank
erwirken will
in dieser situation hätten wir von ihnen
gewünscht ein klares bekenntnis zu
stabilität zur finanzpolitischen
eigenverantwortung sie wollen herrn
makro helfen mit dem was sie sagen in
wahrheit ermuntern sie aber nur
begründung durch diese äußerung
eine diskussion die sie auf gemacht
haben ist ja der eu-haushalt werden dem
den medien dass der arm staatsminister
rot völlig alleine in brüssel war bei
den verhandlungen über den eu
finanzrahmen alle anderen unserer
partner in europa sagen wir wollen erst
wissen für was wir geld ausgeben bevor
wir entscheiden ob ihr mehr geben die
deutschen sind die einzigen in brüssel
die sagen wir geben mehr geld und wollen
danach sprechen wofür
damit haben sie uns in die
schlechtmöglichste verhandlungs position
gebracht und wir sind damit allein
liebe eher fragwürdigen berbalk sagt
europa zuerst ja in der tat aber frau
kollegin baerbock man ist nicht europa
freundlich in dem man zu allem ja sagt
sondernutzung richtigen sollte man ja
sagen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
dieser staat schöpft aus dem vollen
2007 waren es noch 540 milliarden euro
gestand gesamtstaatliche einnahmen 2022
werden es 900 5 milliarden euro per
annum seien bei null zins und nahezu
ohne inflation und in diesen zeiten ist
die schwarze null in der tat kein
fetisch dass man das betont ist ja schon
eine sehr defensive position die
schwarze null ist mitnichten ein fetisch
denn angesichts der zukunfts lasten die
durch ihre rentenpolitik noch vergrößert
werden ist die schwarze null die letzte
haltelinie interesse
enkel generation sie ist sie ist ein
symbol für stabilität in europa denn der
verzicht auf schulden gibt uns autorität
auch anderen stabilität zu empfehlen
und angesichts von rekordeinnahmen und
nullzinsen ist es eine kunst das ist
überhaupt nur eine schwarze null ist bei
disziplinierter politik wären enorme
haushaltsüberschüsse möglich und nötig
frau bundeskanzlerin
stattdessen stattdessen hat sich diese
regierung für 100 milliarden euro
mehrausgaben im koalitionsvertrag
entschieden
und immerhin 46 milliarden euro davon
sind bereits eingeplant der
bundesinnenminister und csu vorsitzende
seehofer hat gesagt die milliarden für
soziales das sahen die antwort auf die
bundestagswahl als ob die da wegen des
pflegenotstands hier sitzen würden das
sind andere gründe
aber es zeigt trotzdem eine mentalität
wenn der in der csu vorsitzende sagt die
milliarden für soziales sind die antwort
auf die bundestagswahl
das heißt mit geld zustimmung kaufen und
diese methode die kenne ich aus dem
rheinischen karneval
das ist kamelle politik und damit kann
man im karneval beliebt werden aber die
größte volkswirtschaft in europa kann
man so nicht führen
und in den in den etwas vornehmeren
worten des ggew hotspot bmf fasste
social dominanz so schreibt der
chefvolkswirt ludger schuknecht in einem
aktuellen wissenschaftlichen beitrag
sozialausgaben verdrängen andere
wichtige schwerpunktsetzungen die
wirklich wichtige aufgabe des
sozialstaats ist aber menschen aus der
abhängigkeit zu befreien damit sie ein
leben in eigener verantwortung führen
können und dafür schon dafür ist für uns
die bildung die schlüsselaufgabe
schaut mal in den entwurf des
bundeshaushalts stellt man fest dass
ausgerechnet der zentrale etat des bmbf
zu den wenigen gehört die 2017 keine
auswüchse zu verzeichnen haben das ist
eben genau die falsche
schwerpunktsetzung viermal mehr für die
rente als für die bildung fragt ein keil
zwischen die großmütter und ihre enkel
für den digital parkschule sind keine
gelder eingestellt machen wir uns das
bitte klar wer soll finanziert werde ich
habe gleich nochmal darauf zurück durch
ein sondervermögen das gebildet werden
soll durch die auktion von
mobilfunklizenzen
und das zeigt wenn es aus einem
sondervermögen kommt ganz offenbar ist
nicht daran gedacht diesen mittelansatz
zu verstetigen
sie wollen das grundgesetz verändern
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben darauf
hingewiesen dass sie dafür die
zustimmung auch von
oppositionsfraktionen brauchen ja mit
dem bundesfinanzminister auch in dieser
frage bereits besprochen andere auch
schon selbstverständlich sind wir
konstruktiv und begleiten das aber wir
wollen die frage stellen nach der
qualität
was passiert mit dem geld und uns ist
wichtig dass es sich nicht um ein
einmaliges strohfeuer handelt sondern
dass der bund dauerhaft mitverantwortung
für die wichtigste
gesellschaftspolitische frage übernimmt
das ist nämlich die voraussetzung dass
nicht nur in steine und tablets
investiert wird sondern auch in köpfe
nämlich in die qualität von lehrerinnen
und lehrern
sie haben frau bundeskanzlerin
gesprochen ihr über künstliche
intelligenz und digitalisierung freudig
begrüßen wir dass wir in den
bundeshaushalt stellte aber fest es gibt
einen neuen titel künstliche intelligenz
dieser titel ist aber mit null euro
befüllt
das ist keine künstliche intelligenz das
ist keine intelligenz und deshalb sollte
es am ende der haushaltsberatungen dafür
einen mittelansatz leben im übrigen ist
es mutig frau bundeskanzlerin dass sie
über das thema digitalisierung und tempo
machen genau heute an diesem tag
sprechen
ich begrüße ihren ehrgeiz in der frage
aber das heute zu machen das zeug
wirklich von courage denn am heutigen
tag ausgerechnet berichten die medien
darüber
das ist bei der versteigerung von 5 g
mobilfunklizenzen zu verzögerungen
kommen wird
die 2018 breitbandziele werde schon
nicht erreicht nach britischen studien
haben der ein lte-netz das nur noch in
russland und moldawien schlechter ist
und beim zukunfts netz 5g dass sie für
das autonome fahren brauchen gibt es
jetzt eine verzögerung von mindestens
neun monate
wie die aktuellen neuen pläne der
bundesnetzagentur zeigen deutschland
kann es sich nicht leisten weiter zeit
zu verspielen weil sie die falsche
politik machen
frau bundeskanzlerin denn sie versuchen
ja folgendes sie versuchen folgendes sie
versuchen das kunststück einerseits
flächendeckende versorgung von
denjenigen zu verlangen die sich an der
aktion beteiligen und gleichzeitig
maximalen
beides zusammen gleichzeitig geht
offenbar nicht oder geht zu lasten der
zeit deshalb setzen sie auf
marktwirtschaft setzen sie auf
öffentliche fördergelder ein
beispielsweise durch die teilveräußerung
der deutschen post denn dieses land
braucht bei der zukunft infrastruktur
endlich einen platz in der champions
league und nicht am abstiegs ende der
tabelle
die erhaltung dieser regierung frau
bundeskanzlerin hat ihr
wirtschaftsminister ausgedrückt als er
davon sprach dass gegenwärtige wachstum
das ginge noch 20 jahre so weiter
paradiesische zustände
bedauerlicherweise sagen die ersten
zahlen im jahr 2018 etwas anderes wenn
nach den zahlen des statistischen
bundesamts hat sich das wachstum im
ersten quartal 2008 10 gegenüber dem
letzten 2017 halbiert bei aller
sympathie sollten wir uns also auf die
seherischen fähigkeiten von peter
altmaier allein nicht verlassen sondern
die gegenwärtige stärke als ansporn
begreifen auch in der zukunft genau
diese wirtschaftliche stärke zu
verteidigen
diese wachstumszahlen sind kein grund
für alarmismus aber für wachsamkeit der
exit demografischer wandel handelskriege
digitalisierung möglichen zuspitzungen
in der währungsunion
alle diese risiken stehen eben nicht im
haushalt für sie wird keine vorsorge
getroffen
frau merkel sie haben hier den
internationalen währungsfonds eben
zitiert aber nicht vollständig sie haben
über die öffentliche infrastruktur
investitionen gesprochen und
digitalisierung der verwaltung all das
haben sie zitiert aber der
internationale währungsfonds empfiehlt
neuerdings und das ist eine neue stimme
aus washington neuerdings auch
steuerentlastungen wenn es einmal gute
nachrichten aus washington gibt dann
ignoriert die regierung sie auch noch
wie kann man sie zurück
so jetzt könig olaf scholz großzügig
eine dämpfung der kalten progression an
der finanzminister
der verzicht auf automatische
steuererhöhungen das ist keine
entlastung sondern ein gebot unserer
verfassung und eine frage der ehre liegt
die deutsche exportwirtschaft gerät
unter druck
unter druck die usa senken
unternehmenssteuer und frankreich auch
sie wollen nichts tun und den
unternehmen auch unseren großen den
internationalen wettbewerb stehenden
familienunternehmen auch noch den soli
ab verlangen wir schlagen vor ohne
alarmismus mit vergleichsweise schmal
mittel eine sofortmaßnahme befristete
sonderabschreibung für digitale
wirtschaftsgüter damit gibt damit die
privaten investitionen angeschoben
würden werden und damit auch die
produktivität der wirtschaft erhöht wird
so ganz zum zweiten senkung der
sozialabgaben unter 40 prozent
der bundesfinanzminister spricht davon
jeder solle 2000 euro brutto im monat
verdienen
ein wunderbares ziel aber wie wäre es
damit er scholz die fangen mal mit der
senkung von steuern und sozialabgaben an
was sind die wand liegt und nötig ist
der komplette entfall des soli bis zum
ende dieser legislaturperiode und zwar
für alle
das wäre die minimale deutsche antwort
auf den steuerwettbewerb in der welt sie
sagen wir können es uns nicht leisten
wir sagen wir können es uns nicht
erlauben irgendwann die höchsten
steuersätze der welt zu haben und was
jetzt die hre zwischenrufe oder
angesagte spd ich will sie daran
erinnern in ihrem eigenen wahlprogramm
haben sie geschrieben von 15 milliarden
euro steuerentlastung insbesondere kampf
gegen den mittelstandsbauch 15
milliarden euro hat auch die union im
wahlkampf versprochen was ist aus diesem
zusagen geworden
10 milliarden beim soli hieß es bei den
koalitionsverhandlungen in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung sind es
jetzt schon nun auch 9,08 binnen weniger
wochen ist eine ganze milliarde in den
plänen verdunstet wenn das so weitergeht
kommen dann ende gar nichts raus und ich
weiß ja was kommt ich weiß ja was kommt
ich kenne ich ja aber gestern auch schon
gehört die unionsfraktion wird wird
jetzt riesige entlastung und vorrechnen
haben wir gestern schon gehört und
werber werden sozialtransfers und
subventionen und steuerliche maßnahmen
in einen topf geworfen und dann wird ein
summen strich darunter gemacht einer der
ja genau sagt volker kauder
einer der großen vordenker der sozialen
marktwirtschaft wilhelm röpke
der hat einmal davor gewarnt aus dem
wohlfahrtsstaat ein tag und nacht
arbeiten das pumpwerk der einkommen zu
machen weil aber in den niemand mehr
weiß ob er zu den gewinnern oder zu den
verlierern von umverteilungspolitik
gehört deshalb den menschen das geld
erst zu nehmen es durch die klebrigen
fingern der bürokratie zu leiten ihnen
dann zurückzugeben und ein dankeschön
von den menschen zu erwarten das zeugt
von ihrem verständnis ist verhältnis
bürger und staat
und gestatten sie mir einen
abschließenden letzten komplex die frage
der einwanderung
denn eine wende in der integrations und
einwanderungspolitik ist auch angesichts
der zahlen im haushalt nötig die
fiskalischen folgen wären sonst
unkontrollierbar und es gibt auch noch
um mehr es geht um den sozialen frieden
im land
die menschen erwarten entscheidungen die
der praktischen alltags vernunft genügen
und vor allem handlungsfähigkeit des
rechtsstaats trotz oder wegen csu und
horst seehofer steht es momentan bleiben
und ja herr kollege
ich werde meine zuneigung für das
deutsche handwerk heute nicht nachkommen
aber hier geht es um eine ernsthafte
frage bei der anbahnung was werden sie
jetzt gleich auch merken
bislang steht noch eine neuregelung des
familiennachzugs bei ihnen im raum
der normenkontrollrat hat ihren
regierungsentwurf in der luft zerriss
der genügt nicht der praktischen alltags
vernunft der menschen und er genügt
nicht den anforderungen des
normenkontrollrats bei menschen ohne
dauerhafte bleibe perspektive macht der
familiennachzug auch keinen sinn
konzentrieren sie sich auf klar
definierte einzel und narrte fälle statt
auf ein kontingent wir haben ihn dazu
vorschläge und das kann ich verstehen
dass die spd in dieser frage grüner als
grün ist ansonsten hören wir aus ihrer
regierung nur worte der islam gehöre
nicht zu deutschland
das ist genauso spalterisch wie in
bayern kreuze an die wand zu nageln
sie mögen sie mögen von machthabern
träumen aber deutschland ist ein
weltoffenes tolerantes land wir
beurteilen menschen nicht danach woher
sie kommen oder woran sie glauben
sondern ob sie bereit sind verantwortung
für ihren lebensunterhalt übernehmen und
unsere rechtsordnung akzeptieren
es wird lamentiert über eine anti
abschiebe industrie wenn menschen die
legitimen mitteln des rechtsstaats
nutzen kann und darf man ihm keinen
vorwurf machen
dann muss gegebenenfalls das stadtrecht
und verfahren ändern
wo sind dazu die vorschläge recht und
verfahren zu ändern wenn es angeblich
eine antike abschiebe industrie gibt die
anker zentren frau bundeskanzlerin die
sie eben gelobt haben gibt es ebenfalls
nur auf dem papier über die
modernisierung des einwanderungsrechts
ist ein besseres management sollte die
bundesregierung also schnellstmöglich
mit denen ins gespräch kommen die das
umsetzen müssen nämlich ländern und
kommunen
wenn sie wirklich etwas bewegen wollen
dann rufen sie umgehend an migrations
gipfel von bund ländern und gemeinden
ein paar seehofer
mit großem unverständnis verfolgen wir
das chaos im bundesamt für migration und
flüchtlinge
es ist die rede von einem eigenleben der
behörde prüfungen von schütz gründen
erfolgen nicht sorgfältig lesen wir in
den medien und offenbar wird nach einer
robin hood mentalität zum schaden von
steuerzahlern und rechtsstaat
entschieden
nach medienberichten hat die hausleitung
spätestens am 14 april umfassende
kenntnis erhalten nach medienberichten
am vierten april spätestens zwei tage
später hat der bundesinnenminister in
nürnberg noch lobpreisungen zu protokoll
gegeben nimmt man zu ihren gunsten nur
einmal abstimmungsprobleme in der spitze
des innenministeriums an beruhigt das
dennoch nicht
diese vorgänge müssen restlos aufgeklärt
werden damit verschwörungstheoretikern
kein boden gegeben wird bislang bislang
voll überzeugen uns ihre tat in der
einwanderungspolitik nicht und ihr
aufklärungswille und das streben nach
transparenz in der frage bundesagentur
für migration und flüchtlinge auch nicht
um es anders zu sagen sie sind einen
schritt entfernt von einem
parlamentarischen untersuchungsausschuss
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen einen
sorgsamen umgang mit dem reichtum der
bürgerinnen und bürger sehen wir beim
vorliegenden haushalt nicht anders aus
die regierung glauben machen ist diese
außerhalb gerade nicht solide
denn er nimmt zukunftsrisiken nicht in
den blick er ist gerade nicht sozial
wenn er tut nichts verlässlich für die
bildung und erst gerade nicht
zukunftsorientiert bei den wesentlichen
fragen wie der digitalisierung sind sie
blank
unser wohlstand wird auf kosten nächster
generation verlebt damit wollen wir uns
nicht zufriedengeben
der partei- und fraktionsvorsitzende der
fdp christian lindner gewohnt
scharfzüngig zu den transatlantischen
beziehungen forderte er einen
eu-sondergipfel formulierte erneut die
sorge vor einer schuldenunion und gegen
andy hier drohte er horst seehofer gar
mit einem parlamentarischen
untersuchungsausschuss
nächste gegnerin ist jetzt die partei
und fraktionsvorsitzende der spd andrea
nahles
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen ist stimmt mich sehr traurig
dass der fraktions und parteivorsitzende
fdp dieser zentralen debatte zum
haushalt 2018 nicht ein gutes wort zu
europa gefunden hat offensichtlich der
linken seite sie sich ganz bewusst
offensichtlich haben sie sich ganz
bewusst in die wirtschafts nationale
tradition der luca sd 1
dieses erbe mögen sie antreten es
verschärft aber ganz klar den blick
darauf was wir brauchen wir brauchen
mehr zusammenarbeit auch mehr
finanzielles engagement deutschlands auf
der europäischen ebene denn das ist die
einfach da viele probleme die diese welt
hat verletzt
und es geht auch hier nicht unter
sondern wir beraten hier heute in diesem
haushalt wieder das hart erarbeitete
steuergeld der bürgerinnen und bürger
dieses landes einsetzen wollen darum
geht es und da geht es zum beispiel ganz
konkret um die frage gibt es eigentlich
in zukunft auch noch gut bezahlte
arbeitsplätze in der lausitz bevor die
braunkohleförderung zu ende geht dafür
haben die 15 milliarden regionale
wirtschaftshilfe in diesem haushalt
eingestellt es geht um die frage
die kinder in unseren schulen digitale
arbeitsmittel endlich zur verfügung
haben um sich auf die zukunft auch
vorbereiten zu können und es geht um die
frage wer kommt denn die rentnerin der
35 jahren wo sie es redlich verdient hat
endlich mehr als sozialhilfe und der
grundrechte deutschen fans
das hat sämtlich und seltenste das sind
keine fans sondern das sind die themen
das sind die bedürfnisse das sind die
fragen die die menschen in unserem land
beschäftigen und ich sage ihnen es
beschäftigt die menschen auch mit
familie wenn sie den vater nur am
wochenende sehen weil er ganz weite wege
zu bündeln hat denn bezahlbarer wohnraum
ist in der nähe des arbeitsplatzes oft
nicht mehr viele zimmer und deswegen
haben wir die cdu csu und die spd
fraktion eine wohnraum offensive auf den
weg gebracht und dafür stellen die
mittel zur verfügung für neuen wohnraum
zu schaffen für eigenheimförderung und
auch dafür dass mieter in der rechte
bekommen denn wir wollen nicht mehr dass
gezielt menschen in diesem land aus
ihren wohnungen heraus modernisiert
werden und deswegen gibt es jetzt mit
kappungsgrenze
hier kosten und es wird funktionieren
wenn das passiert und das haben sie
waren themen die die menschen in unserem
land beschäftigen
die frage können sich pflegebedürftige
menschen darauf verlassen dass die
menschen die sie pflegen überhaupt noch
zeit dafür haben weil sie genügend
kolleginnen und kollegen haben die mit
ihnen auf der schicht sind und können
sich die menschen die auch in gewissen
haben die merken dass die unter stress
stehen darauf verlassen dass diese
pflegekräfte auch gut bezahlt werden
auch dafür haben wir mit diesem haushalt
die grundlage gelegt denn wir
investieren in dieser deutlichen 0 8000
stellen sofortprogramm die pflege denn
es geht um neue mindestbesetzung
schlüssel in jeder schicht inhalten heim
event gemausert
dafür haben wir die finanziellen mittel
in diesen sechs milliarden zur verfügung
gestellt also ich kann wirklich sagen
das sind die fragen die vielen unter den
fingernägeln brennen und ich glaube
deswegen ist die ganze debatte ob das
hier ein haushalt ist
investitionshaushalt oder nicht da muss
man jetzt schon wirklich eine
leseschwäche haben
dieser haushalt ist voller investitionen
alleine 15 milliarden mehr für den
ganzen komplex bildung und das sage ich
mal an dieser stelle was wollen wir
damit machen
ich möchte damit zum beispiel das bafög
verbessern aber auch die
meisterausbildung die kostet nämlich
7500 euro und das kann sich dieses land
sich leisten müsse
diese stelle die weichen in eine ganz
andere richtung stellen und auch ein
thema
frau bundeskanzlerin hat das eben
angesprochen bezug auf die altenpflege
wir bezahlen aber auch in anderen
berufen die wir dringend inderin
brauchen wo fritz ist der käfer mit dem
gute kita gesetz jetzt richtige weichen
stellt aber eines möchte ich doch mal an
der stelle sagen wir haben auch da ganz
viele offene stellen die nicht besetzt
werden können und deswegen gehört auch
das schulgeld für
erzieherinnenausbildung schlichtweg acht
erzielten ausbildung in deutschland muss
genügen zwei werden und deswegen sag ich
an dieser stelle ist diese hausherr
übrigens wenn man das mit der letzten
legislaturperiode hat das büro und
insgesamt 100 milliarden mehr ausgibt
für familien für kinder für
sozialleistungen
das ist auch investition ich weiß das
ist ein alter streit ich sage das sind
die sozial investition wenn wir das
kindergeld erhöhen und den
kinderzuschlag verbessern das ist doch
auch investitionen in die zukunft
unseres landes
und jetzt sind wir uns zitiert wir als
gesetzgeber die in diesem haus das
parlament wir werden uns da einbringen
und das ganze voranbringen denn es geht
um ganz konkrete fragen die die menschen
beschäftigt ich sage ihnen zum beispiel
haben wir eine wichtige frage schon
angeschoben
dafür bin ich sehr dankbar auch der
ministerin katarina barley einer für
alle klage sage ich als stichwort es
sind millionen menschen in deutschland
von deutschen autokonzern betrogen
worden
sie müssen mit enormen wertverlust ihrer
autos rechnen und ich sage ihnen meine
heimat ist das thema eines was ganz
vorne und ganz häufig an den
stammtischen diskutiert und die leute
kalkulieren auch damit und deswegen
haben sie auch das recht dass sie ihre
rechte stärken und mit der einer für
eine klage
passiert das heimat sagt anne können
davon profitieren
dieses prinzip möglich
geschädigten endlich die möglichkeit
geben auch zu ihrem recht zu kommen und
ich sage deswegen wir sollten aufpassen
dass wir diesen guten start mit guten
initiativen den wir jetzt auch hatten
mit der neuen bundesregierung auch
weiterführen wir packen die großen
themen an und wir handeln
dafür sorgen auch übrigens tausende von
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern bei
polizei und sicherheitsbehörden in der
justiz und in den gerichten
sie sichern rechtsstaatliche abläufe in
diesem land und sie sichern damit auch
den inneren frieden in diesem land
wir verlangen übrigens von diesen
mitarbeitern dass sie sich penibel an
das gesetz halten und das machen die
auch was aber soll unsere polizei und
justiz eigentlich von politikern halten
die von rechtsbruch reden wo es keinen
gibt die umwelt als saboteure des
rechtsstaates bezeichnen die neutralität
des staates mit füßen treten und so tun
als wäre das problem unseres
rechtsstaates dass menschen ihre rechte
wahrnehmen
nein das ist nicht das problem die
unsere schlechten tag ist und ich muss
dieser stelle sagen wir haben doch
längst und stand nicht noch verstanden
die menschen erwarten doch dass unsere
rechtsstaatlichen prinzipien für jede
frau und jeden mann egal woher sie
kommen egal ob manager oder flüchtling
gelten und dass wir auch in der lage
sind als staat dieses durchzusetzen
das können sie von uns verlangen und
deswegen haben wir ein pakt für justiz
auch aufgelegt mit 2000 zu stellen
zusätzlichen stellen übrigens für die
richterinnen und richter 2500
zusätzlichen stellen bei der justiz und
15.000 zusätzlichen polizeistellen ja
wir haben verstanden aber den
rechtsstaat aufgeben
das werden wir nicht tun liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sollten uns so nichts und niemanden
daran hindern lassen
der blick auf die wahren
herausforderungen unseres landes zu
schlichten und dies auch anzunehmen
die umsetzung der vorhaben dieser
koalition und die investitionen die in
diesem haushalt angelegt sind
entscheiden über die zukunft unseres
landes
wer die im koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte
vorhaben dagegen blockiert schadet
unserem land und ich sage an dieser
stelle wir die räder anfängt
vereinbarungen in frage zu stellen
schadet unserem land
und wer nebenschauplätze eröffnet statt
sich ans umsetzen unserer vorhaben zu
begeben er schadet unserem land
wir wollten uns allen bewusst sein das
möchte ich da sagen dass die menschen
von uns erwarten dass wir gemeinsam viel
schaffen und das dürfen sie auch
und ich sage das auch im blick auf ein
zentrales vorhaben dieses
koalitionsvertrages das ist das
rückkehrrecht und teilzeit in vollzeit
viele frauen in deutschland sitzen in
der zeit von 1,7 millionen teilzeit
beschäftigte geben an dass sie mehr
arbeiten wollen
wir haben in diesem land ein
fachkräftemangel wir haben gut
ausgebildete frauen 1,7 millionen
vollzeitbeschäftigte davon sind die
meisten frauen wollen dass sie mehr
arbeiten können ja warum mit helfen wir
ihnen nicht dabei
dieses gesetz ist überfällig
wir stehen hier wir sind
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart wurde
und da möchte ich schon mal etwas sagen
wir es offen sich ein reizthema ist auch
beim bundesverband der deutschen
arbeitgeber das ist auch hier darum geht
die beweislast umzukehren was heißt dass
das ist ein technischer begriff der
nächste frau sagt sie wieder zu den
fortschritten der arbeitgeber sagt nein
geht nicht dann ist die rechtliche lage
so dass die frauen nachweisen muss es
geht doch erst mal unter uns hier in
diesem plenarsaal gehabt irgendeiner
dass es ernsthaft möglich ist ich sage
deswegen hier stehen den spieß um
denn die frau teilzeit vollzeit
aufstocken und arbeitgeber sagt nein da
muss der arbeit bekunden aber der grund
warum das ist nun wahrlich nicht zu
verleihen und es wird auch nie münchen
in der deutschen wirtschaft um bringen
und das ist das minimum was zu tun
beschäftigten frauen in diesem land
nicht sagen deswegen an dieser stelle
auch sehr klar dass wir bei uns auf der
seite der spd keinen redebedarf mehr
haben sondern nur noch umsetzungs bedarf
sieht schon der haushaltsentwurf sieht
46 milliarden euro mehrausgaben für
diese legislaturperiode vor und aufgrund
der steuerprognose wie wir gehört haben
sind weitere 10 8 milliarden an
spielraum drin
und deswegen hat olaf scholz für den
bundeshaushalt auch den vorschlag
gemacht
ein teil dieser überschüssige digital
frau einzuschüchtern wir haben ja heute
gemerkt dass das auf breite zustimmung
stößt
und es ist auch richtig investiert ich
sehe dagegen keinen anlass die geringen
zusätzlichen spielräume die wir haben
auch noch in den verteidigungshaushalt
zu stecken und der verteidigungsausgaben
wachsen im vergleich übrigens zur
letzten legislaturperiode bereits es
gibt bereits einem aufwuchs im
verteidigungshaushalt auf 38 milliarden
euro
und jetzt frage ich mal auch die
zuständige ministerin
sie haben in den letzten zwei jahren das
geld was sie bekommen haben nicht
ausgegeben und sie haben es nicht
geschafft aufgrund von wir haben es
nicht geschafft auf bunte inneren
zustände und ineffizienzen in der
bundeswehr
und wenn die von merkel ihr den peter
struck lobt da möchte ich an dieser
stelle mal sagen ja er hat heute noch im
westen und rufen der bundeswehr als
sämtliche seiner nachfolger
das allerdings
es ist auch wahr das management der
bundesheer muss verbessert werden
im übrigen noch mehr geld für die
bundeswehr will und wir wissen alle dass
es probleme gibt mit verlaub wir haben
auch ausrüstungs schlecht und da sind
wir immer bereit was zu tun aber wir
sind nicht bereit die zusätzlichen
spielräume in diesem maße rhein zu
stricken
ich möchte deswegen auf fragen wo sollen
wir sonst das geld hernehmen wollen wir
mehr schulden machen dafür sollen wir
höhere steuern auf reiche und vermögende
erben wollen wir in anderen haushalten
ein strahlen wer das hier permanent und
zwar einseitig und ohne rücksprache mit
uns öffentlich fordert als kampagne der
muss auf diese fragen beantworten wir
alle übrigen auch zusätzliche stellen
bei der bundesagentur für arbeit
darüber freue ich mich wir haben
verabredet dass wir das auch in die
absenkung der arbeitslosenbeiträge
investieren
das werden wir auch tun wir haben
verabredet 0,3 prozent und ich glaube
das können wir machen es gibt noch
zusätzliche spielräume für die spd ist
klar jetzt müssen wir die
qualifizierungsangebote für arbeitnehmer
und arbeitnehmerinnen zu verbessern
es kann nicht sein dass wir immer nur in
sonntagsreden über die digitalisierung
und die notwendigkeit der qualifizierung
im digitalen wandel
wir müssen dann aber auch die
kreativität aufbringen gast konkret mit
maßnahmen zu unterlegen und in die
qualifikation unserer arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer zu investieren und ich
sage an dieser stelle sehr deutlich wir
haben immer noch in deutschland das muss
man sich mal vorstellen
15 millionen erwerbstätige und 30 ohne
abgeschlossene berufsausbildung und ich
habe da haben wir mittel und wege in der
bundesagentur dreijährige ausbildung
brauchen wir haben uns dem herrn stehle
darüber auch die rede wir brauchen
zusätzliche initiativen bei dem programm
wegebau
das ist für mich klar die spd wird
keiner zusätzlichen beitragssenkung
zustimmen ohne das nicht vorher bessere
qualifizierungsangebote für arbeitnehmer
vereinbart worden sind liebe kollegen
mit großer sorge erfüllt uns in diesen
tagen die internationale entwicklung
die aufkündigung des atoms mit dem iran
durch die usa und die eröffnung der
us-botschaft in jerusalem sind schwere
fehler und haben weitreichende
konsequenzen
die jüngste ereignisse in palästina sind
furchtbar
die zahl der toten und verletzten sind
wirklich unfassbar
die letzten stunden haben vor allem eine
tragische entwicklung zu zeitigen
sie haben wirklich die radikalen kräfte
auf allen seiten verstärkt die ersten
demonstration in gaza waren auch gegen
die hamas mittlerweile hat die hamas ich
diese ganze bewegung unter den nagel
gerissen
wir können nicht abseits stehen und wir
wollen auch nicht abseits stehen wir
wollen weiterhin alles dafür tun damit
das leben der jungen israelis der jungen
palästinenser nicht weiter in einen
strudel der gewalt sinnlos geopfert wird
ich bekräftige an dieser stelle was ich
hier vor wenigen wochen auch gemacht
habe ausdrücklich dass existenz und im
übrigen auch ausdrücklich das
selbstverteidigungsrecht israels
aber auch hier muss gelten die
verhältnismäßigkeit der mittel muss
gewahrt bleiben es muss jetzt um
deeskalation auf beiden seiten gehen
der un-sicherheitsrat ist für uns der
legitime und richtige ort übrigens wenn
es um eine beruhigung einer so
angespannten situation geht wie jetzt
zwischen israel und palästina wir
bedauern dass es nicht gelungen ist sich
auf eine unabhängige untersuchung der
gewaltsamen auseinandersetzung zu
einigen wenn die usa ernsthaft eine
rolle im schwierigen nahost
friedensprozess einen wollen dann dürfen
sie sich solchen schritten nicht
verweigern
und gleichzeitig einseitig fakten bei
den politischen kernfragen schaffen
das geht nicht mit einseitigkeit ist das
falsche mittel
sollte deutschland im kommenden jahr im
un sicherheitsrat eine rolle ein neues
gewicht bekommen dann werden wir uns als
stimme des friedens einbringen da bin
ich mir sicher dass wir uns hier alle
einig sind
die internationale sicherheit braucht
die fähigkeit zu entspannung und
übrigens auch die fähigkeit zum
kompromiss und wir werden auch für den
erhalt des iran abkommens kämpfen mit
unseren europäischen partnern dem iran
und den anderen unterzeichnung des
abkommens und wege finden die handel mit
dem iran weiterhin möglich sein kann
die voraussetzung ist dass sich ja eher
an die verpflichtungen hält aber auch
hier gilt ist eskalationsspirale
schlicht zu verhindern dass bonn
abgestimmte und robben könnte vergehen
des amerikanischen präsidenten zeigt
dass wir europäer umso mehr gefordert
sind
ich bin der bundesregierung deswegen
dankbar dass es sich in den letzten
wochen auf allen ebenen bundeskanzlerin
außenminister finanzminister wirklich
bemüht hat die europäische union stärker
wieder zusammenzubringen
wir müssen den zusammenhalt in europa
stärken dazu gehört auch dass wir
zukünftig mehr mittel in den
europäischen finanz haushalt einbringen
werden als in der vergangenheit ja wir
haben das im koalitionsvertrag
verabredet und es war weitsichtig wenn
man sich die aktuelle lage anguckt die
europäische integration ist
grundvoraussetzung für wohlstand und
sicherheit in europa und den
zusammenhalt europas
den müssen wir doch stärken darum ist es
momentan nicht gut bestellt
als größter profiteur der europäischen
union ist es auch unser ureigenes
eigeninteresse in die stärken
etwas zu investieren der das acht lanes
6 an dem ast auf dem wir alle sitzen
die spd tritt oft innerhalb der
bundesregierung für eine klare haltung
hier ein
olaf scholz hat hierzu gerade intensive
gespräche mit den europäischen
kolleginnen und kollegen er hat das
gestern auch klar dargestellt wir sind
auf dem weg in den europäischen
stabilitätsmechanismus
weiterzuentwickeln
unser ziel ist es einen europäischen
währungsfonds zu erreichen
wir sind auf gutem weg das bankenwesen
in europa sicherer zu machen
die unterstützen gemeinsame mindestsätze
bei den unternehmenssteuern was mir auch
ein sehr wichtiger punkt ist und wir
unterstützen auch gerechte besteuerung
großer konzerne gerade auch der
internetkonzern auch wenn ich frau
merkel recht gebe das nicht das alles
nicht ganz leicht ist aber das ziel muss
hier klar benannt werden
und ich habe keine zweifel dass die
bundeskanzlerin und der
bundesfinanzminister hier konkrete
fortschritte hinbekommen werden die
berühmte antwort auf makro mann war
jetzt für die rede fällt bei uns allen
vielleicht etwas weniger pathetisch aus
das ist aber auch aus meiner sicht
völlig in ordnung
entscheidend ist dass wir wirklich ganz
konkret und das habe ich gerade
dargelegt an der integration europas
zusammen mit den franzosen und den
anderen partnern arbeiten und dass das
früchte trägt noch bis zum sommer
dessen bin ich gewiss und da bin ich
zuversichtlich und dafür steht diese
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
fraktionen volk und ganz als ihre
kolleginnen kollegen
wir haben eine menge uns vorgenommen in
diesem koalitionsvertrag
es geht jetzt auch darum uns darauf zu
konzentrieren das anzugucken
dabei gibt es sicherlich weiter auch
kontroverse debatten
das ist auch notwendig dass auch richtig
solange wir dabei nicht die prioritäten
aus dem auge verlieren die menschen in
deutschland erwarten dass wir etwas tun
damit diese welt ein sichererer ort wird
dafür ist europa von zentraler bedeutung
die menschen erwarten dass sie mehr
sicherheit im eigenen land haben
dafür investieren wir nicht nur in die
justiz sondern auch in die sozialen
probleme die die menschen verunsichert
und deswegen ist dieser
investitionshaushalt den wir heute
vorlegen ein wichtiger beitrag um
deutschland voranzubringen in diesem
sinne fangen wir doch einfach an das
umzusetzen was wir verabredet haben
andrea nahles die spd partei und
fraktionsvorsitzende engagiert
verteidigte sie hier den oder falls
gesamt eingebrachten bundeshaushalt auf
der anderen seite machte sie aber auch
klare ansagen gegenüber dem
koalitionspartner cdu/csu
sie forderte dass teilzeit vollzeit
gesetzt nun endlich in kraft zu treten
die spd habe keinen redebedarf sagte sie
und ebenfalls kritisiert sie die
bemühungen die verteidigungsausgaben
hoch zu teilen das ist eine rolle die
andrea nahles hier heute gut eingenommen
hat durchaus kritisch gegenüber dem
koalitionspartner aber nicht opposition
in der koalition das ist ja auch nicht
einfach für sie in der doppelfunktion
als spd vorsitzende und fraktionschefin
wird sarah wagen
für die bundeskanzlerin die gewalt im
nahen osten eskaliert wenn es europa
nicht gelingt das atom abkommen mit dem
iran zu retten dann droht ein
flächenbrand
wir begrüßen ist dass die frau
bundeskanzlerin sich von dieser
gefährlichen politik donald trump
distanziert haben wir haben schon lange
eine eigenständige und selbstbewusste
europäische außenpolitik gefordert und
wir sind froh dass wir mit dieser
position heute nicht mehr alleine stehen
aber wenn sie denn auch die
bundesregierung inzwischen einsieht dass
die amerikanische politik unsere
sicherheitsinteressen widerspricht und
das ist fatal wäre sich dieser politik
weiter unterzuordnen
ja dann müssen sie doch jetzt auch die
notwendigen schritte unternehmen wenn
sie frau merkel sie haben öffentlich
kritisiert dass der bruch des iran
abkommens zitiere sie das vertrauen in
die internationale ordnung verletzt
das ist richtig aber das vertrauen in
die internationale ordnung das wird doch
seit jahren verletzt
das wird noch verletzt bei jeder
gelegenheit wo das völkerrecht mit füßen
getreten wird das wird doch überall dort
verletzt
das wird doch überall dort
eine große militärmächte und allen voran
die vereinigten staaten sich anmaßen
länder deren regierungen ihnen nicht
gefallen oder die ihnen ihre rohstoffe
nicht zu den gewünschten konditionen zur
verfügung stehen militärisch zu
verwüsten
das waren iran so das war mir auch so
das war ein lügen so sie haben folgende
entwicklungen genannt aber sie haben sie
genannt als sei das vom himmel gefallen
dass diese länder destabilisiert worden
das war doch kriegspolitik und die
jüngst militärschläge gegen syrien auch
die wahren völkerrechtswidrig und die
haben sie leider sogar noch gegrüßt und
wenn sie wenn sie das vertrauen in die
internationale ordnung wiederherstellen
wollen dann gehört dazu dass sie diese
unverantwortliche politik des wird
changes die immerhin schon über eine
million menschenleben gekostet hat dass
sie die unmissverständlich verurteilen
und dass sie klarstellen dass
deutschland einen krieg gegen den iran
weder direkt noch indirekt unterstützen
würde da würde ich gern mal was von der
bundesregierung
zweitens zweitens wenn sie ehrlich sorge
vor einer weiteren eskalation im nahen
osten haben ja dann hören sie doch bitte
endlich auch in dieses pulverfass auch
noch waffen zu liefern
das kann doch nicht wahr sein erklären
dass sprechen sie
seit jahren versprechen sie uns eine
restriktive rüstungsexportpolitik und in
wahrheit dielen sie hemmungslos mit den
rüstungslobbyisten und sie liefern
diktatoren wie erdogan
oder wie den saudis genau die waffen die
sie brauchen um ihre blutigen kriege in
syrien oder eben auch in jemen zu führen
das doch eine völlig unverantwortliche
politik so stunde pro stunde sterben
weltweit vier menschen durch deutsche
waffen
wir finden dieses verbrechen muss
endlich ein ende haben
und drittens auch das gehört zu einer
eigenständigen politik steigen sie
endlich aus dem vom tram
vorangetriebenen wettrüsten aus im
letzten jahr haben die europäischen
nato-staaten 300 milliarden dollar für
rüstung ausgegeben die nato insgesamt
900 milliarden dollar 900 milliarden
dollar
sie haben vorhin doch darüber geredet
fluchtursachen zu bekämpfen ein zehntel
dieser summe von diesen 900 milliarden
würde genügen damit auf dieser welt kein
einziges kind mehr verhungert oder ein
armutskrankheiten stirn 900
und ich sage ihnen zum vergleich zum
russland russland gibt 66 milliarden im
jahr aus wir reden also über eine
relation von 900 milliarden zu 66
milliarden und da erzählen sie uns allen
ernstes wir müssen noch weiter aufrüsten
damit gut die nicht vielleicht morgen
vor den toren von berlin steht wie krank
ist das denn was sie hier bereichen und
das ist doch schon etwas sein der
rüstungsetat ist der einzige wo sie
nicht kleckern sondern klotzen und dabei
sind waffen und kriegsgerät und das
finde ich das wirklich schlimme dieser
großen koalition offensichtlich mehr
wert als die kinder in diesem land denn
während sie für bessere kitas gerade mal
3,5 milliarden sich abbringen können
sollen die rüstungsausgaben um
mindestens 5,5 milliarden steigen und
wenn es nach frau von der leyen geht
sogar um zwölf milliarden können sie in
irgendeinem steuerzahler erklären warum
sie mit seinem partner arbeiteten geld
einem solchen schicken oder treiben das
ist doch wirklich überhaupt nicht
zurecht
und es gibt noch einen schritt es geht
noch einen schritt wenn sie wirklich
eine eigenständige politik wollen dann
pendeln sie die eiszeit mit russland und
heben sie die unsäglichen sanktionen auf
ja es stimmt ja es stimmt auf der
anschluss der krim
auch der anschluss der krim bar
völkerrechtswidrig und trotzdem brauchen
wir die kooperation mit russland wenn
wir probleme lösen wollen das sehen wir
doch jetzt bei dem beispiel ihrer und
auch sicherheit in europa gibt es nur
mit russland und nicht gegen russland
das war doch die kern einsicht die
damals den neuen aussenpolitik der neuen
ostpolitik von willy brandt zugrunde
gelegen hat und diese tradition hat auch
die deutsche außenpolitik über viele
jahre geprägt und da müssen wir doch
dahin zurückkommen stadt diese wichtige
tradition jetzt von einem amateur im
außenamt endgültig entzogen zu lassen
das wird der falsche weg
und das können sie doch als spd schon
gar nicht mit
und ja es geht auch um wirtschaftliche
interessen ist ihnen wirklich noch nicht
aufgefallen dass sie russland sanktionen
in erster linie europäische die
europäische wirtschaft treffen und
darunter ganz besonders die deutsche
wirtschaft oder dass es vor allem
europäische unternehmen sind die nach
der kündigung des iran aufkommens jetzt
probleme drohen
ich finde die frechheit mit der der neue
us-botschafter sich in die
geschäftspraktiken deutscher unternehmen
eingemischt hat die spricht doch bände
und statt vier russische diplomaten
auszuweisen
die wirklich überhaupt nichts verbrochen
haben wenn man vielleicht diesen
hemdsärmligen kollegen lieber die
heimreise nahe legen soll eine
eigenständige
eigenständige europäische aussenpolitik
kann es natürlich auch nur in einem
einigen europa gehen geben und das
verlangt nicht weitere zentralisierung
sondern es verlangt eine politik der
guten nachbarschaft im unterschied zu
ihnen haben wir dem wahlsieg von mappus
vor einem jahr nicht frenetisch berufe
jubelt und wir stehen heute an der seite
derer die sich in frankreich gegen
sozialabbau zu wehr setzen
aber der arge gerade den motor wenn es
hier im hause gerade den müsste es doch
zu denken geben wenn man krank ist die
deutschen exportüberschüsse und die
deutsche sparwut als antieuropäisch
kritisiert und in dem punkt hat er doch
wirklich recht wenn ausgerechnet die
größte deutsche volk die größte
europäische volkswirtschaft
rücksichtslos weiter auf lohndumping auf
exportförderung und auf einen schwachen
binnenmarkt setzt dann macht sie nicht
nur politik gegen die eigenen
arbeitnehmer sondern sie macht eben auch
politik zu lasten unserer nachbarländer
und das untergräbt den europäischen
zusammenhalt das ist doch völlig
offensichtlich und dabei
dabei ist die regierung eigentlich in
einer komfortablen situation
sie haben hoch steuereinnahmen sie
können sie zu lasten von konzernen und
superreichen sogar noch weiter erhöhen
und dann tatsächlich auch mittel und
geringverdiener spürbar entlasten nicht
nur symbolisch wie sie es vor haben die
neue zinsen vergrößern ihren haushalts
spielraum noch weiter und zwar
beträchtlich
sie hätten alle chancen der welt
deutschland zu einem innovativen und
gerechteren land zu machen
aber was machen sie trotz eines
investitionsstaus von 120 milliarden
euro bleiben die investitionen und zwar
auch nur wenn man ganz gut willich
rechnet bleiben die investitionen auf
dem jetzigen kläglichen niveau und das
obwohl sie zur zeit das geld von den
banken fast geschenkt kriegen wenn sie
das für investitionen einsetzen würden
aber diese grandiose diese grandiose
landschaft von schwarzen und roten
nullen schaut lieber weit dazu wie
straßen brücken und öffentliche gebäude
verrotten wie innovative unternehmen am
langsamen kind internet verzweifeln und
wie funktelefon hatte in deutschland in
manchen gegenden an strenger sind als in
vielen entwicklungsländern
das ist doch keine haltbare situation
obwohl sie wissen obwohl sie wissen dass
in folge der digitalisierung in zukunft
vor allem qualifizierte und
hochqualifizierte arbeit gefragt sein
wird obwohl sie das wissen
schicken sie unsere kinder weiter in
marode schulen wo die lehrer fehlen wo
der unterricht ausfällt und wie jedes
jahr etwa einige tausend junge menschen
verlassen ohne auch nur richtig lesen
und schreiben gelernt zu haben frau
merkel ich finde ja beeindruckend und
ich finde es auch richtig was die hier
zur förderung der künstlichen
intelligenz gesagt haben aber die
natürliche intelligenz die intelligenz
der kinder und jungen menschen in diesem
land die sollten sparer ablassen und vor
allem vor allem im sozialen brennpunkt
sind die zustände an vielen schulen eine
einzige katastrophe
kinder die hier ins ins leben starten
haben nie eine echte chance
wenn es nach ihnen geht wird sich daran
auch nichts ändern denn die summe die
sie jetzt zusätzlich bereitstellen
die wird noch nicht einmal verhindern
dass in vielen schulen weiter hinter
deckt der putz von der decke fällt und
ich finde ja auch interessant die große
koalition auch sie frau merkel freute
nicht aber manchmal schon sprechen
neuerdings wieder von sozialem
zusammenhalt begrüßen wir ja sehr
aber ich sag mal wie der soziale
zusammenhalt zurzeit in deutschland
beschaffen ist in diesem jahr bekommt
das geschwisterpaar quandt und klappen
zwei leute aus seinen ärzten der bmw
anteile eine dividende von 1.100
millionen euro überwiesen 1100 millionen
euro für zwei personen
und gleichzeitig streiten sich die zahl
25 prozent ja da würde sich mancher
arbeitnehmer freuen wenn er mit 25
prozent hätte und gleichzeitig teilten
sich an den tafeln die schweiz die sich
an den tafeln immer mehr arme darunter
auch viele rentnerinnen und rentner
viele alleinerziehende vom abgelaufene
lebensmittel ist das ein sozialer
zusammenhalt begehen sie wie sie ihn
sich vorstellen wir würden das er ob der
kapitalismus
es gibt keinen es gibt kein land in der
eu in dem die zahl der beschäftigten die
trotz arbeit arm sind so stark gewachsen
ist in den letzten jahren die in
deutschland und was tut die große
koalition teilweise prangern sie
öffentlich die missstände an die sie
selber herbeigeführt haben das hat man
bei der rede von frau nahles wieder
eindrucksvoll gehört aber sie ändern
nichts jeder in diesem land weiß dass
ein mindestlohn von 8 eur 84 nicht zum
leben reicht
die bundesregierung hat vor kurzem
ausgerechnet dass man mindestens zwölf
euro 63 braucht um nach 45 jahren
vollzeitarbeit eine rente oberhalb der
grundsicherung zu bekommen herr scholz
hat mittlerweile ein mindestlohn von 12
euro gefordert
ja ich finde das sehr gut wenn sich die
spd
und fortan schließt aber wie erklären
sie es dann irgendeinem ihrer wähler
dass sie in eine große koalition gehen
ohne eine erhöhung des mindestlohns auch
nur gefordert zu haben
ich habe noch nicht mal die frage
gestellt in den unternehmen in der die
umgangsformen immer wieder bei amazon
werden beschäftigt dennoch auf der
toilette digital überwacht bei der post
muss man inzwischen eine bärenstarke
gesundheit mitbringen wenn man einen
unbefristeten vertrag haben will
einige von ihnen haben das öffentlich
beklagt aber wenn sie nicht wollen dass
arbeitnehmer immer schutzloser solchen
praktiken ausgeliefert sind dann ändern
sie endlich die gesetze die das alles
doch erst ermöglicht haben
sorgen sie dafür die natur es lieber wer
in diesem land von den jobcentern
gezwungen wird die kehre unter tariflich
bezahlte arbeit annehmen zu müssen
verbieten sie sach- und lose
befristungen nicht wieder mit tausend
hintertürchen haben sie eine
jeder arbeitslosenversicherung wieder
hier statt arbeitslose nach einem jahr
mit hartz4 zu enteignen und alles zu
bringen was sie sich im leben aufgebaut
haben jetzt wollen sie schon wieder den
beitrag zur arbeitslosenversicherung
senken und den unternehmen ein
milliarden geschenk machen
nehmen sie das geld und verlängern sie
die bezugsdauer von arbeitslosengeld 1
das wäre doch mal eine richtige maßnahme
für mehr soziale saison
was haben sie im wald was haben sie im
wahlkampf nicht alles für bessere pflege
versprochen
jetzt soll es 8000 stellen mehr geben
bei 40.000 fehlenden stellen allein in
seniorenheimen und mindestens 70.000
fehlenden stellen in den krankenhäusern
8000 stellen werden an den schlimmen
zuständen in vielen pflegeheimen nicht
das geringste ändern und das wissen sie
auch herr spahn hat jetzt angeregt noch
mehr osteuropäische arbeitnehmer in der
pflege einzusetzen
vielleicht sollten sie hier sparen
lieber mal darüber nachdenken warum sich
kaum noch junge menschen für eine
ausbildung als pflege entscheiden
vielleicht hat das damit zu tun dass es
nicht sehr attraktiv ist knochenarbeit
für hungerlöhne zu leisten und es ist
vor allem auch zutiefst ungerecht jede
einzelne pflegekraft leistet mehr für
das allgemeinwohl als alle
investmentbanker zusammen und deswegen
muss diese wichtige arbeit endlich an
bezahlt werden ich meine das ist doch
wirklich tragisch es gibt nicht ein
problem dass sie entschlossen anpacken
nicht eine herausforderung der sie sich
wirklich stellen so kann man doch nicht
in eine wahlperiode starten ohne ideen
ohne jede vision ohne einen einzigen
großen gedanken oder irgend ein
wichtiges vorhaben so kann man doch
nicht anfangen
vor kurzem wurden die bürgerinnen und
bürger danach gefragt wer heutzutage die
macht hat und die wenigsten gaben an
dass sie der meinung sind dass die macht
bei den politikern liegt und nahezu
niemand glaubte dass die bevölkerung die
macht hat wie es ja eigentlich in einer
demokratie sein sollte
die wertzahl gegen davon aus dass es die
wirtschaft die großen unternehmen nur
die reichen sind die dieses land
regieren und ich werde ihn ja nicht
unterstellen dass das ihrer absicht ist
aber wenn man den menschen besonders
überzeugend demonstrieren will dass sie
nicht mehr in einer demokratie leben das
sie wählen
können was sie wollen und es ändert sich
überhaupt nichts es geht all das weiter
die gleiche konstellation die gleiche
politik der sich genau vorher
nachdrücklich bei der wahl eine rote
karte gezeigt haben
und wenn man auch noch dem letzten
gutgläubigen verdeutlichen will das
wahlversprechen nichts anderes sind als
wohlkalkulierte lügen dann muss man es
genauso machen wie sie es machen
ich finde das unverantwortlich sie haben
vorhin gehört fast hätten inzwischen im
bundestag erhalten dass solche regelung
menschen gegeneinander ausgespielt
werden menschen gesetzt werden dass
solche reden hier im bundestag möglich
geworden sind das ist das ergebnis
dieser politik und sie denkt noch nicht
mal darüber nach diese politik endlich
zu verändern finde das wirklich zum
verzweifeln das kann doch nicht so
weitergehen
viele menschen machen sich sorgen um die
zukunft eine mehrheit wünscht sich mehr
sozialen ausgleich sie ärgert sich dass
gerade die größten unternehmen oft die
niedrigsten steuern zahlen und die
politik nichts dagegen tun
sie fordert eine besteuerung großer
unternehmen sie will keine aufrüstung
sondern investitionen in die zukunft und
was machen sie
sie machen einfach das gegenteil sie
subventionieren konzerne und füllen die
auftragsbücher der waffenschmieden aber
sie sind nicht bereit kinder und alte
menschen vor armut zu schützen
in einem land das die vielleicht besten
autos dieser welt baut erklärt sich die
politik für unfähig pflegebedürftigen
alten menschen eine lebensabend in würde
zu ermöglichen
frau bundeskanzlerin wo es diese große
koalition sie erwägen ja gerade einen
werteunterricht für flüchtlinge
einzuführen also ich würde ihnen
dringend raten vorher erstmal ihre
eigenen werte zu überprüfen
wenn ja so kann es weitergehen
wir brauchen dringend wir brauchen
dringend eine andere politik wir
brauchen eine politik die auch das
rückgrat besitzt auch
interessenkonflikte mit mächtigen
einflussreichen lobbys und
interessengruppen durchzustehen eine
politik die endlich wieder das tut was
ihr auftrag in einer demokratie ist
politik für die mehrheit zu machen und
nicht nur für die reichen
da man nicht erhält viel applaus für
diesen engagierten vortrag aus ihrer
fraktion
und sie hat den finger nochmal tief in
die wunde gelegt aus ihrer sicht die
finanzieren für der falschen ruhe haben
im haushalt der region
werke von finanzminister olaf scholz
nächste rednerin jetzt hier katrin
göring eckardt die fraktionschefin der
bundestags- dass die sich über den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt wir
gedanken machen
ich finde es aber in diesem kontext
genau verkehrt dass sie versuchen die
osteuropäischen pflegerinnen dann am
ende doch gegen die auszuspielen hier
aus unserem land kommt dass windig
sollten sie sich noch einmal überlegen
bei den arbeitsbedingungen gebe ich
ihnen recht
sie haben heute viel über die aufgaben
geredet die vor uns liegen sie haben
heute gezeigt dass sie dass diese
koalition die mitglieder dieser position
eigentlich mit dass das land im umbruch
ist
sie hätten die mittel dazu sie haben die
möglichkeiten dazu
und wenn man sich dann den haushalt
anschauen und wenn man sich dann schon
etwas real gemacht wird dann sind sie
eben doch gefangen in den alten routen
in den alpen es geht weiter so in einem
haushalt leben nicht für die zukunft
gemacht ist sondern so eine
fortschreibung so eine art wiedervorlage
des alten meine damen und herren
und natürlich ändert sich da draußen die
welt die haltung die sehnsucht und ich
habe mehrere wege in aachen angeschaut
und haben sie hat micron gelobt für die
begeisterungsfähigkeit für europa wieso
einen putzigen welt und sie sie haben
gestanden und genau das nicht gemacht
und ich habe das auch heute hier nicht
gehört frau nahles hat gesagt wir sind
ja vielleicht nicht so
begeisterungsfähig
aber du meine güte darauf kommt es doch
an es kommt doch jetzt darauf an dass
wir auch ausstrahlen dass wir für dieses
gemeinsame europa sind es kommt doch
jetzt darauf an dass wir das geld auch
bereitstellen und das hat der
finanzminister eben leider nicht gemacht
in seiner ankündigung hier gestern
es kommt doch darauf an dass wir zeigen
wenn der iran die gekündigt worden dass
von den fachkundigen vereinigten staaten
dass wir in europäisch gemeinsam
und nicht nur darüber reden es kommt
doch es kommt auch darauf an dass wir
zeigen dass wir die friedensmacht sind
und eine friedensmacht frau merkel und
frau von der leyen ist man nicht indem
man einerseits immer über europa und
gemeinsame außenpolitik redet und auf
der anderen seite dann eben doch wieder
nur den etat für die deutsche bundeswehr
auch stoppt die eine verdammt schlechten
umgang mit den finanzmitteln hat und
deswegen akzeptieren beratung ist meine
damen und herren dieses gemeinsame
europa für dass es jetzt wirklich auch
leidenschaft braucht und auch das
eintreten dafür auch in schwierigen
zeiten das könnten sie jetzt zeigen sie
haben ja schon eine ganze menge von
krisen gemeistert und auch fehler
gemacht eine die wir behaupten ja immer
den größten viel hatten sie 2015 gemacht
ich glaube da haben sie ihn gerade nicht
gemacht da haben sie aus einer
notsituation heraus richtig entschieden
sie den frieden gegangen
trotz aller konsequenzen und
nebenwirkungen die diese historische
situation nun an bringt aber jetzt
könnten wir vor einer situation stehen
wo der größte fehler genau jetzt
passiert indem sie dieses europa eben
auch nur versuchen mit zu verwalten in
kleinteilige zu verfallen und ich kann
nur hoffen dass die vorschläge die sie
hier angekündigt haben genau das
gegenteil sind dass europa groß gedacht
wird das tatsächlich die verantwortung
für die gemeinsame außenpolitik auf
europäischer ebene liegt das schloss es
mit dem veto damit wir tatsächlich auch
gemeinsam uns tatkräftig handeln können
das brauchen wir jetzt als gegenüber
verdoppelt haben als unterstützung für
die zivilgesellschaft in den vereinigten
staaten das brauchen wir
damit wir uns in europa wirklich
gemeinsam zu hause fühlen konnte warte
ich verliehen klaviere regierung und und
wenn man das wenn man das ernst immerhin
bieber christian lindner
ihre rede auf dem parteitag zu europa
war ich ganz bei ihnen allerdings ja um
einen historischen moment von dem sie
gesagt haben wir seien nicht genutzt
worden
doch was mich wundert wenn die so
vehement ein deutsches ja zu europa
fordern dann heißt das doch dass man
eine gemeinsame verantwortung für die
finanzen wahrnimmt dann heißt das doch
dass man ins risiko geht dass man sich
tatsächlich engagiert und sie hätten sie
hätten wirklich diese möglichkeit gehabt
sie hätten diese möglichkeit gehabt als
wir darüber verhandelt haben für dieses
gemeinsame europa einzutreten genau das
genau das haben sie nicht gemacht sie
wollen anderes europa rentner
sie wollen nein wir haben nur dieses
eine europa das ist das problem
wir haben nur die designerin
und das zu gestalten und dafür können
wir gemeinsame verantwortung übernehmen
und manchmal reicht es eben nicht mit
aufs plakat zu schreiben manchmal muss
man eben den mut auch an der richtigen
stelle haben
si die armee werde sagt vielleicht ist
es auch diese mut sache die sie brauchen
dass sie mehr frauen eine möglichkeit
geben möchten
auch das habe ich mir genau angeschaut
sie an irgendwie von gender geredet als
ob das was ähnliches wäre sehe ich
anders
ja das findet ihr die auch darauf habe
ich gewartet ich finde herr lindner
machen sie es einfach so dass mit den tv
das regelt der markt ist
machen sie den frauen einfach bessere
angebote und zukunftsperspektiven denn
so trägt man spitzenfrauen in die
politik und nicht damit dass man darüber
redet dass sie vielleicht ein bisschen
besser aussieht meine damen und herren
liebe kollegen
frau merkel hat gesagt herr seehofer
braucht noch ein bisschen schonfrist
weil es noch nicht 100 tage sind dann
habe ich mal schnell gerechnet
das innenministerium ist in unionshand
seit 4500 zutage
und wenn es dann darum geht was man noch
nicht im griff hat dann finde ich kann
man schon mal auf diese 4500 tage diese
sehr lange verantwortung der union
blicken
herr seehofer seit wochen torpediert
ihre partei die csu das grundgesetz
markus söder von rechts und er wird von
rechts ein
mit dem bayerischen
polizeiaufgabengesetz darf gegen
unschuldige bürgerinnen und bürger
ermittelt werden ohne konkreten verdacht
der protest dieses gegen dieses gesetz
ist verfassungspatriotismus meine damen
und herren das was ich erwarten ein
das ungewisse das stellt den weg starke
zentrale und herr seehofer sie sind
verfassungsminister und man muss sich
wirklich wünschen man muss sich wirklich
inständig wünschen dass sie unsere
verfassung jetzt mal gegen die csu
verteidigen
ich bin daher sollte man da nicht so
viele
die hessen hatten gar nicht so viele
kreuze aufhängen dass man an sie beten
könnte dass es bald vorbei ist dass der
landtag endlich gewählt ist dass diese
populistischen auswüchse aufhören und
vor allem dass die csu endlich einen
koalitionspartner kriegt damit der
vernunft einzieht meine damen und herren
liebe frau nahles
ich habe mir sehr genau angeschaut was
der hauptteil bietet für gerechtigkeit
erstmal habe ich mich gefragt warum
haben sie eigentlich glaube 13 stunden
verhandelt um das finanzressort damit am
schluss
wolfgang schäuble olaf scholz und sonst
ändert sich eigentlich nichts noch nie
hat eine regierung noch nie hat eine
regierung mit so viel geld so wenig
gemacht die einnahmen steigen und das
land fährt trotzdem weiter auf
verschleiß wo finde ich denn die von
ihnen angesprochene soziale
gerechtigkeit sie können sich doch nicht
hinstellen und über die pflegekräfte
reden und am ende kriegen sie nicht mehr
als ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
selbst der meister hatte 25.000 liege
kräfte gesprochen und sie sind mit 80
kräften ich war in der letzten woche und
in den wochen davor in der ganzen reihe
von pflegeheimen und die leute fühlen
sich vor karte sagt man das bei mir zu
hause sagen das ist nicht mein sohn
dass wir eine kraftkur pflegeeinrichtung
mehr haben das kann doch nicht sein dass
dort das gegenteil von gerechtigkeit ist
es doch der versuch leute ruhig zu
stellen und kleines karo zu machen meine
damen und herren
aber am meisten hat mich erschüttert
wie lange wir heute eigentlich über die
große existenzfrage ökologie gerettet
worden ist
frau merkel in ihrer rede wenn ich es
richtig angepackt haben uns glaube ich -
dem gedenktag für die bienen eine minute
ist es neue jetzt an der koalition dass
man nicht noch nicht mal mehr so tut als
ob die ökologische zukunft des landes
irgendwie wichtig ist sie stehen oben
auf der zugspitze und machen schicke
fotos dabei wie sie dem der klimakrise
zu schauen wie der gletscher schmilzt
und am ende des tages haben sie nicht
drin mal den hintern in der hose mit
einem einzigen beschluss zu mehr
klimaschutz herunter dass es noch keinen
fortschritt
hoffen wir dass diese nennen
und natürlich brauchen wir sofort den
ausstieg aus der kohlekraft diese
verzögerung spiele mit noch wieder einer
kommission die werden nicht mehr weiter
funktionieren wir werden sie übrigens
auch nicht daran messen was sie
irgendwie miteinander verabreden konnten
und ob sie diese ziele einhalten wir
werden sie daran messen was ökologisch
was in dieser existenzfrage tatsächlich
notwendig ist und ich will es noch mal
sagen nur damit es um die vielleicht
noch mal in ihrem kopf hinein kommt
jedes jahr müssen durchschnittlich 26
millionen menschen ihre heimat verlassen
wegen extremer klimaschutz
die unwetter nehmen zu 2017 haben stürme
erdbeben überschwemmungen ein schaden
von 330 milliarden euro verursacht das
ist die wirklichkeit übrigens auch die
ökonomische wirklichkeit und daran
messen wir sind ihr auf der
regierungsbank sitzt das große
ökologische schweigekartell deutschlands
vergangenes jahr haben sie noch alle
gelacht als über das bienensterben
geredet worden ist aber jetzt macht man
das nicht indem man mal daran denkt dass
das vielleicht ein problem ist in
hannover hat ein supermarkt gerade mal
gezeigt was ohne bienen werden
die haben 60 prozent der produkte aus
den regalen genommen
ohne bienen gäbe es keine babynahrung
und vielleicht das schlimmste für manche
keine schokolade
das alles ist systemrelevant täglich
verschwinden bis zu hundert tierarten
und es entstehen keine neue ich will
eine politik die dafür sorgt dass 2020
schluss ist mit dem paten sterben ich
will eine regierung dass die das tut und
meine damen und herren sie von der
regierungen sie müssen das wollen wenn
sie irgendetwas für die zukunft dieses
landes und die zukunft dieser erde tun
wollen so geht es nicht weiter
sie können da sie können darüber lachen
weil meine wenn man sich wenn man sich
die afg anschaut und wie sie immer über
heimat und so was alles reden dann kann
ich nur sagen wenn man wenn sie daran
ich denke wenn sie darüber lachen können
dann haben sie komplett verfehlt was
deutsche politiker in dieser zeit auch
tatsächlich tun müssen man kann sich die
die verschmutzung der meere mit plastik
anschauen oder heute haben wir noch mal
was über den diesel gehört das war
dieselbe platte die ich schon hundertmal
gehört habe und das war dieselbe platte
die mich immer von der autolobby hören
natürlich geht es darum dass unsere
automobilindustrie das macht was sie
verschlafen hat nämlich in die zukunft
zu investieren
aber es muss doch auch darum gehen dass
die leute die betrogen worden sind von
der selbe autoindustrie jetzt auch
tatsächlich eine entschädigungsregelung
hardware nachrüstung das wieder recht zu
machen das ist echtes versagen von
politik und das ist auch misstrauen dass
die leute dann immer weiter haben wir
und auch da haben wir nochmal sagen wer
war eigentlich zuständig in den
vergangenen jahren ein neustart hin oder
her
aber zuständig beim wesentlichen grund
immer die csu dafür dass das alles
passieren konnte dafür dass die themen
unter der decke geblieben sind und dafür
dass die autoindustrie einfach so
weitermachen konnte meine damen und
herren ich finde was am meisten gefehlt
hat in ihrer rede frau merkel das war
das große thema wie will man eigentlich
den zusammenhalt in dieser
gesellschaften statt
sie haben gesagt sie hätten das erkannt
dass die leute nicht mehr drauf schauen
wollen wir jetzt zuständig ist und
deswegen kommen jetzt
grundgesetzänderungen und darüber können
und müssen wir ja auch gerne reden aber
nur ums zuständig seien alleine geht es
ähnlich es geht auch um großes denken
nehmen wir mal das schöne beispiel
wurden wir haben
situation dass es eine der größten
sozialen fragen dieser zeit ist die
leute fürchten vom land in die städte
weil die jobs und bessere infrastruktur
suchen was sie finden das schlechte luft
keine kita plätze und was sie finden
sind verdammt teure wohnungen
unbezahlbare mieten und kein geeigneter
wohnraum und dann sagen sie
baukindergeld baukindergeld und wir
sagen dann 22 milliarden euro die
übrigens keinem einzigen helfen der die
miete nicht mehr bezahlen kann meine
damen und herren das sind steuergelder
gegen den ohnehin schon übersetzten
wohnungsmarkt hineinfließen das ist kein
instrument geht doch um die sparte wie
leben wir zusammen wie organisieren wir
unsere städte wie ist es mit der
infrastruktur bokermann beträgt werden
haben wir genügend features wie ist es
mit der integration meinen wir das
wirklich alles ernst ja oder nein
und das erwarte ich von einer regierung
die wir zusammen leben redet nicht dass
sie in diesem unternehmen punkt mein
kleines burschen verteilt sondern dass
sie die strukturfrage das
auseinanderdriften der gesellschaft die
armuts frage die frage wie lebt die
alleinerziehende heute die am ende des
monats nicht mal das geld hat mit ihren
kindern in jim knopf zu gehen dieses
verlange ich von ihnen großzuziehen in
den mittelpunkt zu stellen wieder
politik denn das ist die größte
betrachtete zusammenhalt nicht mehr
funktioniert meine damen und herren und
daher
er hält doch ganz bestimmt kein hat
ministerium was noch mehr dafür sorgt
dass zu auseinanderdriften kommt diese
zeit da hilft nur dass es sich aufraffen
und dieses land zu einem machen was
modernes was zusammenhalt will und was
die ökologische frage endlich in den
mittelpunkt stellt darf das hat ihnen
herr mang vorgemacht und sie machen es
im kleine karo so geht es nicht weiter
meine damen und herren
noch nie hat eine regierung mit so viel
geld so wenig gemacht hat katrin ekg
fraktionsvorsitzende der grünen
produktion vorgeworfen europa müsse groß
gedacht werden
natürlich spielt in ihrer rede die
fehlende ökologische frage eine große
rolle